what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos like the videos on your way
in and make sure you subscribe to the
channel as you guys already know if you
have watched two or more of my lives and
you do not subscribe we have beef people
okay so a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily make sure you go subscribe
to both also guys we have four
membership tiers the first first allows
you to be part of the live chat tonight
the second you get to be a part of our
Discord and our behind the scenes Vlogs
the Discord I get a lot of my topics
from so if you guys want to be involved
in picking the topics for the show make
sure you sign up for the Discord
um also if you want to see me freestyle
rap it's in the behind the scenes Vlog
so that's on the second tier third tier
you get to connect with me on social
media and the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month how
do you get a million subscribers in a
year do you want to know sign up for the
fourth tier also guys they took away my
Instagram so make sure you go subscribe
or go follow my Instagram just pearly
things one they also took away my first
second third and fourth Tick Tock so
make sure you go for follow my fifth
Tick Tock justperlythings.5 and just
probably think six that's my backup in
case they take that one away
because they just
I really I just try to give my thoughts
and they just they punish me for it you
know we also have a new animation
Channel just pearly animation so make
sure you subscribe to that we only have
one official pregame page so if you are
getting messages from random people
random WhatsApp WhatsApp numbers it's
not me okay look it we have one official
pregame page
also
a thousand likes today and we will open
up the chat so um today we have a lovely
panel so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about you so
starting here and then we go around
hi everyone my name is Mariam I'm 23 and
a fun fact about me
not really a fun fact but just effective
just
the fact that I study neuroscience and
psychology
okay my name is Jackie I'm 21. a fun
fact about me is
it's not really a fat more than a
description but I'm very outgoing myself
I like to do things and I'm that person
that you'll see everywhere basically
right
um I'm a vetanis I'm 21 and I'm in a
relationship
fun fact about me is I did I'm a dancer
I guess
nice
hi thanks for having me I look really
red on the screen I don't know why that
is but um I'm Siobhan I'm 36 years old
I'm in a relationship and uh fun fact
about me is I once got arrested for
trying to rescue a falcon what how I
lived in Dubai and I called a falcon
person when I saw the bird continuously
hitting itself against a glass building
um but because they're Royal Birds um I
would seem to be accused of trying to
smuggle the bird or something out of the
country but yeah I got away obviously
wow oh my gosh okay um
and also known as just leash I'm 35 I am
kind of I'm in a pending relationship
I'm gonna say he's in the cot he's in
the car we haven't checked out yet but
he's in the car he's in the car he's in
the cart yes exactly what's what's
stopping you from checking out um there
isn't anything that's stopping me I
guess it's just I guess it's the case of
us just having that conversation really
we've kind of been allowing things to be
fluid and this is the first time I'm
actually disclosing this so you're
getting an exclusive today I
love
and a random fun fact about me
um this is super random when I was a
teenager
um I was in a group and I wrapped and we
had a music video on channel uh really
random wow we could wrap it together we
could totally rap together yeah yeah
I've got bars if you've got bars
tier two guys tier two
okay so um I know we have a mixed crowd
when it comes to age so who knows who
Pamela Anderson and Tommy Lee yeah
Hannah yeah you know I don't follow
social okay you don't you guys are yeah
so Pamela Anderson's huge okay so Pamela
Anderson is an actress
um Tommy Lee is a rock star for those of
you that don't know and
um they I was researching them for this
show and they've had just like an on
again off-again relationship since let
me see it says
1994. so they
um got married after four days of
knowing each other yeah
um after they they got married in Cancun
Mexico
and literally they were just on again
off again they also had a sex tape that
was released during
um when they were together
they had two sons and he also was
arrested for abuse
and she still actually got he went to
jail for it and she actually still got
back with him after
and then again on again off again on
again off again until now they're not
together they've separated and he's
married to someone else and she's single
now the reason that I bring this up is
because
recently she has been doing a
documentary
and in the documentary she said
that she texted at 55 she hasn't been
with him for five years she texted Tommy
Lee that he is her one true love
while he's married to someone else
damn so
um my question for the panel was have
you ever had an ex that was incredibly
hard to get over
hmm
and what made him so hard to get over
that one for me I would say
it was really like my first kind of love
so I was at a young age I think I was
like 18 at the time when I got with him
so I feel like when you're at that age
especially us women being so emotional I
just felt really attached to him and
even though I see him doing a lot I feel
like I'd always want to run back to him
everything was there he just knew the
right way to kind of say and I feel like
oh I was too good at getting something
how long were you on again off again
with him so from 18 to 1. from 18 until
I was turning 20. so like nearly three
years and then sorry nearly two years
okay but that one was very serious we
kept going back
um we initially started talking in like
2019 and then by the end of
um 2021 that's when we called it quits
but during that stage during that um
that time period we got together about
three times on broke up three times so
yeah and would you say he was a nice guy
or a bad boy Looking Back Now definitely
a bad guy a bad boy bad guy bad guy yeah
what makes you say that just like
obviously the age I am now in the
maturity I have looking back there's a
lot of things that he used to do like
he'll be very good with his words I know
now when certain guys say stuff they
don't mean it but back then it's very
easy to get sucked in like I said before
and he just used to always know the
right words to say which can be a good
trait sometimes but in relationships
especially as a guy
and what made it so hard to leave just
because he knew the right things to say
he was telling you a dream pretty much
and you know it's that popular it was
popular for me because obviously that
was like my first real proper like
relationship like we moved in together
and everything so it was very serious
and obviously at that age as well I'm
thinking like this is some fairy tale
going on but realizing now and looking
back at it now I wouldn't have done so
many things that I did do and listened
to him the way that I did if that makes
sense okay
um you want to go next yeah um I feel
like my the love that I had is kind of
different to yours in the sense that man
wasn't a bad guy we both really cared
about each other and it was whereas kind
of on and off for some time but he went
in jail and for like three years he went
to jail yeah like three years
um but he wasn't a bad guy no okay okay
so the reason why we always want to see
the good and the drugs
time certain situations it's a cop-out
answer sometimes to say oh you're not a
situation things like that but generally
for this guy like
the way that um he was brought up from
very very young was was not good and it
kind of like that was the path that was
predestined for him but then he's kind
of like got out of it now and I'm like
we're good and everything but
for me it was very difficult to get over
him when he came out of jail
um we wanted to get back together but I
was like you know what you have to
change yourself everything like this
first and he took a year to do it and by
that time
um I was like we're not gonna get back
together but I was still very much in
love with him but I had to just realize
that the amount that I loved him and the
amount that I love myself I'm very
solid on what I want and what I do not
want from a man and um he had a child as
well and in that time the year that he
took to change I realized that I do not
want to be someone who has who already
has a child because I'm selfish I want
to be first for a little bit of the
relationship at least
but um did he change in that year yeah
he did the total 160. so he he was a bit
like more of a bad guy before and then
he like changed into more of a nice guy
he was I mean he was in jail we can't he
was he he was always a nice guy he's
very good got a beautiful heart but I
just feel like he saw that there was
another way to live life rather than the
one that he had been stuck in for that
time
um it just was a thing where I realized
that as much as I love him and as much
as he loves me and all these kind of
things like there's a greater kind of
love like I feel like when you love
people and when people love you it's a
very selfish kind of thing because it's
like I love you I want I want you to be
with me and we're going to make it work
and what I want but I was just like you
know what for the best for what I want
and what you want you can't just keep on
going down this path what what made him
different than other guys that made it
hard for for you to get over him
everyone says that they want honesty I
had this whole time we're talking about
it earlier but he was genuinely very
honest if he did something bad he did
something good like I had a lot of
issues of Trust And even if he did
something bad he was honest and it kind
of made me accept that you know what
even if I might feel like people are
down the wrong road and I have a
stereotype of roadmen that they're that
they're dishonest and that they like to
use words because men know that women
want to hear certain things right and I
feel like men use that to manipulate
women and he showed me that you know
what someone can go be in that lifestyle
want better for themselves and not
manipulate you of words they could just
tell you the truth and if you don't
accept it you don't accept it and then
you have to sort out what you're going
to do from there on so you like that he
told you what it was exactly yes and
that's what made him different you feel
like other guys told you what you wanted
to hear where he told you the truth and
yes and also another thing which I think
a lot of men nowadays really struggle
with is being assertive in a respectful
way like he would not allow me like I
can be a bit I think everyone can be a
bit um push the buttons of it sometimes
you know push the boundaries and stuff
but he always let me know this is not
how it's going to be do not continue
this behavior and I respected that
because he knew the right way to do it
and a lot of men do not know how to do
that nowadays they get angry or they
don't know how to express themselves or
they um blame you and yeah this is just
another one okay okay and what about you
right okay so when I
um was going out with my ex I was very
young compared to him so how old were
you how old was he
[Laughter]
yeah I was 14.
and he was 19.
sorry shot caller everyone yeah but he
actually did ask for Mission from my mom
and dad because he was like I really
like your daughter
and he was he wasn't like a creep he
wasn't giving creep okay he was giving
like
gentlemen actually and he was very kind
and sweet but it was also long distance
as well so he was living in Holland and
I was living here but he would get like
um I think it was like a 12 hour Coach
every two weeks to come and see me and
he was working like two jobs as well at
like 19 years of age
um but I think from that
because I was so young he was my first
everything as well like first
well you know what I mean like first
everything and so I think that's what
kept the attachment for so long but how
long were you with him three years three
years yeah but
I think because I was so young I think I
was just so excited that like an older
boy had liked me really and when I look
back on it now at 21 years of age I'm
thinking
I don't think that's too right if one of
my friends would come to me and say I
like her
15 year old would you think why did your
parents allow that because they saw how
he was because he was a nice yeah he was
a good dude I was literally begging them
as well like if your daughter's growing
like I love him you know what I mean
what can you do right
um
but
I think the attachment was is because I
was so young and I think I was with him
for that long
because I was so young and also didn't
really know what I want so you you would
have said he was a good guy though yeah
not a bad boy good boy no he wasn't a
bad guy at all but I'm in a relationship
now
um and it what made him different was
that you were young it was your first
like guy that you were with yeah okay
yeah literally but um
I look on it
I look on it now as in it was an okay
experience
but we also broke up in between as well
and that's I think
because I was so young
I like Miss the
the love and like the kind of like he
kind of led the way through everything
so I think that's why I went back but I
actually broke up with him because I was
bored you broke up with him because you
were born I broke up with him like three
times just because you were bored
because like one because I was bored
because we what do we have in common
really well you haven't come on with a
14 year old and 19 like we are actually
in different Paths of life and then
he was long distance as well
and
it's just I was growing up and I was
starting to like other things and I was
starting to
actually know what my type was maybe you
know so yeah that's that's the reason
why I think I kept on going back because
of the age okay yeah what about you yeah
I can kind of relate to some of what
you're saying there because my first
relationship I was 16 and he was 20 and
he was already a father
um and again my mum did not want me to
date this guy she would literally pin me
down
what was wrong with them the fact that
he had a child when he was 20. right
okay yeah yeah so yeah it was like
that's not what you want for your 16
year old daughter
um but yeah I fell head over heels in
love with him
um I moved out of home when I was 17.
got my own place he moved in with me so
we were having a very adult relationship
from the age of 17.
um I did end up breaking up with him
because actually what was interesting
was I ended up taking on quite a
masculine role in that relationship I
started earning very well and he wasn't
and I was then paying everything and it
was I lost respect for him to be honest
um and I kind of made it known it kind
of came out as quite an outburst one day
and I was like you know don't feel
embarrassed about the fact that every
time we go to the movies I'm getting my
purse out and every time we get you know
and all this
so he and how old were you did you say
um so at that point when I broke up with
him I was getting on for 19. okay so
you're with him for three years yeah
yeah
um broke up with him um but I loved him
you know I really loved him he
retaliated when I bought that to
Ascension by throwing furniture around
so I was like right you're out you know
that was that he was a bad boy too well
it actually wasn't but he was so ashamed
that it was like he reacted by just
throwing a Jaws like punching the wall
but I'd never seen that side of him
before Oh okay he was soft as a kitten
up until that point and then you said I
pay I pay for all our dates like you you
yelled at him and then he started
punching the wall yeah but but in three
years I'd never seen that side of him
okay but at that point I was like pack
your bags you're gone right yeah he had
to kick him to the curse he had to go he
had to go right but then when he moved
on and got into another relationship I
then started to feel like actually maybe
I still love him and wanted to be with
him so it was almost like when he when
someone else wanted him I wanted him
back you know and then it actually took
a while for me to get over him which was
strange
um wait so you were you were good you
were moved on then you found out he was
dating someone else and you you wanted
him back yeah he wanted me back did you
get him back or no
um no so he he actually was trying to
get me back for a period of time I
didn't want to know but then the moment
he got with somebody else it was a bit
of a toxic trait in me you know I then
wanted him back
um and that that time it was too late
because he then moved on moved him moved
in with someone else and it actually did
take me a long time because I sort of
thought oh you know maybe he is my my
one true love you know
um he made a mistake but he's still a
good guy and I still love him so it did
take me a while to get over that one I
think because it was that first
significant relationship
what about you interesting okay so mine
is a little bit chaotic I guess
um my ex-partner and the father of my
children
um I met him when I was 14 years old uh
is it whip now how old was he he was I
was 14 he was 16. so we were still a
little better yeah what is it with this
oh honestly what are you guys doing
England
it's a bit grooy
Yeah so um so he was like he was my
first ever boyfriend and when I met him
I remember this I was at school and I
met him he came and chatted me up at the
bus stop after school with his friends
um and I thought he was the most
handsome guy that I'd ever seen in my
life and I was super flattered that he
was talking to me
um so we dated I say we dated we're in a
little bit of a relationship for maybe
like a year
um and then he broke up with me
and I was just I was heartbroken I think
at that time I really convinced myself
that I loved him and that I was mature
enough to know what love was and my
friends and my family were like no he's
not for you he's not they were obviously
seeing something that I didn't see
because you're in that bubble of being
in love and this juvenile sense of he's
my everything like at 14 I don't think
you can know what your everything is
um so we we were together first kind of
intimate experience and things like that
and I think that I put that uh I held
that to quite and you know on quite a
pedal stool that I was intimate with
somebody for the first time and so This
Must Be Love and we're going to be
together forever
um we our relationship came to an end
when we was I don't know I think maybe
like a year later I was about 15.
um and I saw other people and things
like that but he would always contact me
so it will be like we wouldn't speak for
maybe like six months or something I'd
change my number and then I'd randomly
bump into him in the street which just
kept fueling this sense in my mind of oh
my God we're clearly meant to be
together when did the kid come and say
he was the father yeah when did the kid
come in so we got back together
um I would say again sort of in line
with that whole us bumping into each
other and me feeling like it's fate it's
meant to be oh my gosh
um fast forward I was 19 I'd moved out
of my parents I was living on my own I
was living a great life I was very happy
um and again I moved it I moved into a
place and on my first day of living
there I've gone to like the local shop
and he's just there and he's like this
is the pub the pub next door is where he
like cashed his checks after work and
stuff so again this just fueled this
we're meant to be this is the universe
this is God bringing us together
um so we got back together when I was
19. we had our daughter when I was 21 uh
our son when I was 20 uh 22 and we had a
10-year relationship wow we separated
when I was 30 when I was 30. he's only
two years older than me so he was 32.
um and it was very in the beginning
stages it was a very I wouldn't say it
was very toxic but I didn't see him for
what he was I was just in this bubble of
I love him and he's who I'm going to be
with forever would you say he was a bad
boy or a nice guy I would say that I
believed he was a nice guy but in
hindsight he's not a very nice person
okay he's a bad like if you if you're
Declassified one he'd be a bad boy yeah
but not like your your stereotypical bad
boy like he's got Edge about him more
like you're just not a very nice person
you're actually very insecure you've got
a lot of issues in yourself you project
a lot of things and I think that was
particularly when we had our children
um we moved away from my parents so I
was quite isolated I lost quite a few of
my friends I didn't really see my family
so all of my relationships started to
take a bit of a hit for This Love that I
thought was going to be forever
um and I would say by the time by the
time I got to 29 I started to see it for
what it was and I started to see he was
quite narcissistic he was quite I would
never want to deform his character and
say he was narcissistic but from my
experience I felt like I was being
emotionally manipulated mentally
manipulated and things like that
um so we separated when I was 30 and it
was actually a really a bad breakup like
really really bad breakup
um so we've been we haven't been
together for five years four and a half
five years and he hates my guts we
co-parent and he's a great father I
wouldn't take that away from him my
children absolutely adore him and he
adores them they see him very regularly
but he he doesn't even give me eye
contact he hates me why I don't mind
um to be honest with you I think
I think that he didn't take the time to
heal from our relationship and if I'm
being really transparent
um I checked out in like the last year
of our relationship I checked out he you
know he was doing his thing he was
unfaithful in the beginning of our
relationship
um it prompted like an open relationship
for like a year which I didn't really
want to have but because he wanted to
have it I kind of agreed with it because
I felt like that was the right thing to
do I never stepped out and did anything
but I would like tell him I was going on
a date and I'd go to like my
girlfriend's house and just chill with
her so that he thought I was going on a
date because I knew that he would be
with someone else it was really bad
really toxic this sounds very this is
very Pammy actually this is quite bummy
so I'm curious out of everyone here what
who was anyone not on to get off on
again off again with the guy
well I would say for the 10 years we
were consistent in the first four years
we were on and off I don't know I've
never done the on and off thing so you
were you're completely on yeah I was on
and off on and off I don't know I don't
know
um because he went in jail it's a bit
yeah
do you think that women like instability
because everyone's for the most part
everyone's ex doesn't sound stable I
feel like
we don't like it it's not really a
choice with them because there's no
stable man
my boyfriend is very stable but there
are a lot I'm very lucky with mine but
there are a lot that aren't so I feel
like if it was up to us it would all be
stable but
there's two of us in it and always one
is not stable you know what I mean yeah
but I mean as a young woman you have so
much Choice like there's so many men in
the friend zone
very stable but we never pick them we
don't do I don't know why we don't pick
them and it's almost like there's like I
don't know like a thrill of the ups and
downs like even with my ex I feel like
part of the reason why I was even so
attracted to him in the first place is
because like he's just unpredictable
like you know them people that you can
call them bad people but they're only
good to you it's that kind of a chat I
don't know if you kind of understand
what I'm saying uh but it's like it it
makes you feel like wow like it makes
you feel special yeah I think women like
a challenge when it comes to love I
think they like to feel that they've got
to win
the guy over I felt that in my younger
days I sound like I'm really old now I'm
not I'm still I'm not old still young
but you know it was that feeling of like
feeling like in some way like when with
the ex you know when I saw him with
somebody else it's like I want to win
him back you know because I felt like I
had to prove that I was the better one
you know I think that's that you can say
that's ego or your pride but I do feel
there is a lot yeah it's literally but I
think it's attached to a sense of
worthiness that you don't feel worthy
for love just to come easy to you that
you have to work for it and I know that
I experienced that growing up with my
mum
um breaking up with my dad when I was
three and I swear to God that woman
probably only in the past few years has
got over him it's taken a long time so I
I I witnessed that my mum always sort of
pining after my dad in this roundabout
way so that's where I learned that
behavior from that feeling like love had
to be about pining for someone craving
them rather than them just coming easy
to you I feel like there's um that's one
way to look at it but from my experience
like I have had something that's like
kind of up and down stuff and I feel
like as women we when we get emotionally
attached we kind of feel like from my
experience I'm like oh you know I know
um that there might be some flaws in
this person but I've seen people change
um they can change too I know the right
way they just have to see the right way
and our relationship people change yeah
I've changed a lot and anyone can change
I think I feel like people get worse
over time actually I actually don't
think I don't know a single person
that's changed completely it depends
which way you flip the coin
you can either come out of a
relationship better or it can drain to
the point where you feel worse in
yourself it depends about obviously the
people that you are before you go there
in the first place I mean I think I hear
a lot of people that say they changed
but then I watch their relationships and
they're exactly the same I think traits
are difficult to change but behaviors
can be changed and mentality can be
changed as well because you have to like
look at the um the personality traits
and the behavior causes and then you
have to look at
um like you have emotional logic and you
have logical logic and you have to
choose which one suits um that situation
at the time it's true yeah when you say
emotional logic okay for example for
example for example I'll use the
situation with one of my friends
um we used to get into arguments because
I would explain to them you have to um
pay attention to your emotions and you
have to work through them that is
logical it's using your emotions but
it's being logical and they were like no
no I don't need to um look at my
emotions right now I have things to
focus on and so on and so forth but the
um unresolved emotions were getting in
the way of them
it sorting out what they need to sort
out because they would just um go and
blush out every so often understand that
that
um
I don't know if you look I guess I was
gonna say like I kind of I feel where
you're going with it but I I disagree I
think their logic and emotion are two
completely different things they are two
completely different things if you're
operating from a place of emotion that
is a feeling it's not thought it's a
feeling that's emotion there's emotional
intelligence though isn't there and
that's yeah well that that's not being
questioned it like the logic is logical
is what makes sense if we look at this
on paper what makes sense this is I'm
going to think this through um what is
logical A to B and emotion is just oh
this is how I feel well I don't women
ever pick partners that make sense
because I think that they lead with
their emotions I think as women we we
tend to and I think that when you are
interested in somebody you you all logic
goes out of the window
sorry I just want to quickly say um
going back to your point
um maybe I did what I said wrong so yes
of course an emotion is a feeling
however you can look at that feeling and
be like is it logical to feel this way
like for instance someone might um say
something and I feel like women do this
a lot um men even actually do people do
this a lot someone will say something to
you and then you'll be like oh are you
trying to say I'm this so and so forth
because you're reacting with a feeling
like um you might feel ashamed so on and
so forth but you have to take a step
back and logically logically look is
this feeling actually
um rooted in my own insecurities
whatever whatever and then if it's
illogical to feel that feeling then
that's what I will call emotional logic
because then you've looked at that
motion with logic obviously there's um
logic that comes that's objective logic
feeling is something um personal and
therefore that's why I separated the two
kind of things so I get what I'm trying
to say you're trying to basically say
like I don't know if someone come and
knocks your drink on your lap or
something and you'll be like
exactly but if you step back and think
about you think oh it might be an
accident yeah I mean like let me just
leave this person alone like so you're
saying sometimes it's about taking
responsibility for your own feelings
that it's not necessarily like
understanding where that feeling is
coming from and tracking yourself in
that sense it's not about um taking
responsibility for your own feeling per
se because sometimes the way you feel is
the other person's fault however it's
about being the bigger person to your
own feelings and be like you know what
I'm big enough that I can deal with this
without I'm projecting it outside and
therefore I'm going to go about this
situation with logic um I'm not
disregarding my own feelings I agree
with you actually I feel like I feel
like your feelings don't matter I mean
as women we feel one way one day we're
about to get our period then we feel
another then then it's like we're in
even this most of us on the couch we're
in for a minute and we go back then we
leave then we go I just I feel like love
is a choice and I feel like I feel like
you're right I think that you know we
should operate with more emotion but we
we don't as women yeah I feel like um a
lot of women um a lot of people in
general I should say they do not
have a lot of organic thoughts their
thoughts are like I was saying earlier
you can make anything make sense and
there's a lot of social media input and
all these kind of things so
um a woman will be like oh you know this
is the man I want because of ABCD
reasons and then they'll get um too
deeply involved in that and then they
won't be able to realize oh this is not
actually what's good for me this is just
what I've been influenced I think that I
want but actually it doesn't really work
for me and then they kind of get stuck
in that cycle kind of thing and that's
to answer your question why don't women
never choose stable guys but then again
if love is a choice then how are we all
just like
not choosing and choosing to like love
these men you know what I mean yeah
because if you choose bad but but we
don't choose it we feel it yeah like you
you fall you can't control the things
you can't control these emotions because
you know the person is bad for you so
why would anyone go I'm gonna choose
that anyway no because you fit like you
love them and it's not a choice you
don't control it though don't you I
think sometimes we just let it get a bit
out I mean you choose who you have sex
with so yeah you know you can feel it
one way you could feel one way about a
guy but you know if you see red flag red
flag you don't have to say sex and love
us are two different things yeah but I
don't know where does it start I feel
like you can't like for example you with
someone for a long time you realize you
know that you love them you can't just
switch it off when you realize that
they're starting to act different you
can't just like just turn it off and
like yeah I Don't Love You No More it
really doesn't work you can make a
choice yeah you can make a choice you
can make a choice to leave them but it's
not going to stop what you feel you get
me like you can still feel away like you
might even miss them because now you
feel like you love the person they've
done you like this but you've left and
now you're feeling like oh that's what
makes people want to go back as well
because it's like oh like you start to
second guess like oh did they even do
this that bad was it was it was it me
was I overreacting like it's it's not a
choice in my opinion I mean how was it
how is it not a choice if you're going
to be with someone or not be with
someone like isn't that a choice
obviously that's you how you can feel
how you feel but that's the choice you
make that's a choice but I meant love is
not a choice like you can't choose to
turn off your feelings for somebody yeah
I feel like feelings are gonna come and
go so if you're going to be married for
50 years do you think you're always
going to feel in love yeah that's what
I'm saying I think it's a choice at the
end of the day yeah but you know your
parents want to beat your brains out
sometimes right like when you're a kid
yeah but they always love you though so
one day my mum can't like tomorrow say
you know what amber Don't Love You No
More it's gone completely but sometimes
they feel like that when you're acting a
certain I do not think that they do so
so you think your parents sometimes are
like Pearl I feel like sometimes they
felt like they wanted to kill me you
know but they still love you though they
still love you but I'm saying it was a
choice my mom's definitely wanting to
come
it's unconditional love with children
yeah if I was to ask like with your kids
I'll turn around to you and say oh maybe
tomorrow you won't love them no more
but that's what I'm saying it's a
different type of love there's different
types of Love isn't there there's not
just one type so there's like a garpi
love that romantic love there's that I
can't think what the children but
definitely with the children it's that
unconditional love whereas with uh with
men or Partners it's it's it is
conditional to some degree but I don't
feel like you choose any of it that's
how and I feel like especially cool like
you know how we're talking about how we
were in relationships when we're younger
I feel like when you're younger you
confuse the different types of love like
you might think okay I love this person
so even if they do this to me it's not
going to stop me feeling this way so it
kind of comes off as unconditional but
obviously at that age you don't really
understand but it's just the feelings I
think sometimes I think women would have
better outcomes if her parents picked a
husband for us no yeah I do actually
yeah yeah I think that arranged
marriages have got very good success
rate not of my mom I don't know because
also sometimes my mum will buy me like a
rug for my room and I hate it and that's
just a rug I think a lot of time we go
after chemistry don't we that's what
we're feeling with these guys is the
chemistry it's not necessarily like this
like you mentioned earlier I hope you
don't mind but you know this sort of
calming effect that this person has on
you I understand that now today to be
love when actually someone is like my
peace and my calm whereas when you're
younger you go after the thrill you go
after the excitement there you know so I
just think that it's also like a
hormonal response when did that switch
for you from going for the exciting guy
to the more calm peaceful guy
um yeah good question I think that um
probably 30 around 30 yeah 29 30 when I
when I when I feel pregnant at 30 yeah I
feel pregnant with a guy I was with
frenzy for like five years and then we
we had a family together very quickly oh
wow yeah yeah and I kind of can't help
but feel that there's a lot there's a
huge difference and I think that for us
sometimes we get them a little bit
confused there's a big difference
between love and lust and and what we
think you know that whole excitement
that thrill that oh this is so not good
for me but I just want it anyway oh he
won wants me he desires me he lusts me
um yeah there's a big difference between
the two and I think when except for me
anyway at the young age that I was I I
don't know if I can leave it the first
phase of our relationship was definitely
Lusty I think I put him on a pedal stall
to some degree
um when we had the kids it was love but
I think it was more staying in a
situation for the for the wrong reasons
if that makes sense
um so now after coming out of that
relationship I was single for a long
time like five years it was single four
um and I I reflect on the chaos that was
the last relationship and the war that I
went through in the end of it so now
that I'm well over the five years sort
of coming to a place where you're
comfortable with yourself you you really
love yourself you really know your worth
and and what you want from a person it
changes your view on on your
relationships but you know how you're
talking about obviously lust and love
and stuff don't you think that
relationships come after last because at
the end of the day for somebody need to
be attracted to you and to want to get
to know you like that is all about
physical attraction how they feel about
you in the beginning so I feel like last
kind of can in a way play interlock
because it comes up not really no one
could turn my head that I really fancy
now I don't care how hot a guy is he
couldn't turn my head now you know what
I mean like if you were chatting to
somebody let's say you find them
attractive whatever they start ticking
your boxes as you go one by one and then
at the end of the day you're gonna start
feeling this person you're going to
start off as a loss yeah you're gonna
start looking attracted it looks fade as
well I think historically women have
gone after looks
yeah I think so yeah no actually I think
the women I think women actually go
after like dominance in a kind of way
like the man who's manly are kind of
thing like even if you look back in
history and stuff they'll go after the
man I don't know who's killed so many
people I don't know but they'll go after
these men that are showing their
strength you get it nobody wants a simp
so at the end of the day everybody wants
to go for a man that's showing his
manliness you don't have to be the best
looking guy in the world but as long as
you are coming off as a man I feel like
you get it I think with dating apps
everybody's so looks focused now it was
a women included you know it's just it's
literally yes no yes I mean how can you
make a decision about your husband by
looking at one photograph on it on a
dating app you know but they're doing it
they're saying no to these guys who are
good guys good character because how
much can you tell from one picture well
you can't but they're making that
decision who do you guys think is
pickier with looks men or women men men
100 men no I think
okay so would you would you say that
dating apps that primarily looks
I've seen a lot of things about like the
captions as well or how they slide into
the deals I've never actually had like a
conversation with a load of girls and
it's about looks not really would you
would you say that when people select on
dating app it's mostly through looks I
don't really know because I've never
really been on anything well I think men
just like really love everyone and then
they Whittle down once they've got all
the matches and work out who they want
to invest time to get to know what
percent of men do you think women swipe
right on
probably 10 yeah yeah I'd think that
because obviously if you're in person
it's the same kind of thing like you get
more guys trying to approach women than
women trying to approach guys I'm not
gonna lie I've never approached a guy
like that and that's unless I was a
drunk or something and I feels for jokes
but
um I don't really do that so I feel like
if men are doing that anyway why not on
a dating app would men not be the ones
to approach the women I don't think the
men are analyzing the profiles like the
women are what percent of the time do
you think men swipe bread and dating
apps oh I was gonna that's why I thought
the question was for girls for girls and
guys I think girls swipe on men like
five percent because we expect men to be
dominant dominant and pursue it um
pursuers but
um men swipe on all the women I think 95
because I have guy friends and some of
them swipe left so I'm just like yeah
they don't even look at that phone
yeah so so who's pickier when it comes
to looks men or women but that's that's
an unfair to say I know guys they will
not find the girl attractive and they'll
still do what they're doing if that
makes sense I feel like I feel like to
base it off a dating app is an unfair
basis because
um when it comes down to it
um men want someone
who they think is beautiful women are
more for um the protection that they can
get what the um how they can build a
future of the man so on and so forth
looks do play um a part however there's
a lot more that feed into it and a man
is going to a man okay so you don't
think on a dating app that's it's mostly
looks that's right so when we're
selecting based on looks who's pickier
that's why I said it's unfair because
the dating app is unfair because a woman
is going to look at a lot more than just
looks because for me I can only speak
for myself actually but when I'm looking
at um someone's profile whatever I'm not
even on dating ads today just to say it
that sounds really bad I'm not in the
dating app for any reason just sometimes
I'm bored but um
but um is this a hobby for you but like
but like because you know like at two
o'clock in the morning like I've done
School through Instagram whatever
whatever I'm just like I'm about to go
to sleep with anyone I talk to you at 2
A.M
this is the bad thing I don't talk to
anyone I'm just like oh let me look at
the weird people are about and that's
what that's what I'm saying if I see
someone who looks weird or interesting
or something like that then I might
swipe right on them have like a small
conversation see what I can learn from
them and then carry on with my day it's
not necessarily about looks and all
these kind of things and um I do you
think women are picky about height oh
yeah I don't know yeah
would you guys date
a guy that is two inches three inches
shorter than you no no because if you're
already shorter than me what about when
I wear heels you're gonna think people
don't think you're my child I think I
have done yes and I'm quite tall I've
dated some of my height no shorter I
said not three inches sort of no no
shorter
no no no no no no no no I'm just curious
out of the guys would you guys date a
girl she looked good three inches taller
than you yeah yeah
blessing yeah he's nodding who's pickier
men or women when it comes to looks
we could do weight even women weigh more
than men
oh this one this one yeah the thing is
yeah no I actually have like a the thing
is with women when women are bigger
like that's based on BMI it's based on
BMI so women have like a worse BMI than
man yeah yeah but that's because we're
curvier and we've got more we've got
thighs we've got hips
but we do have like the extra weight no
one
we're fatter for our height so they yeah
like if you look at BMI of a man and BMI
of a woman women are fatter I think
women have to be picky I don't think
that I'm not saying it's a bad thing no
I'm just saying even with looks we're
pickier we have to be though because at
the end of the day man can go and and do
whatever they want of so many different
women but we have to think about our
future Offspring and all these kind of
things and I'm sorry I'm not going to
pick a man if I think he has bad
genetics if he has bad work drive if he
has bad all of these different kind of
things so I have to be picky what
percent of men do you think are sexually
active one of them no no no no no no no
no 80 of them 80 no no I think 65 I
think 99 40 40 I think this is 40
percent there's a lot of pressure on me
a lot of them are looking after
themselves yeah what about you
oh God I don't like
99.99.99 no just something very high I
don't think anything maybe 80 80
something yeah what if I told you one
out of every three men under 30 or
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year I I believe that okay in which
country you know that this country
America there's a lot of frustrated men
out there there's a lot of insults but
also like if you consider like you know
not every guy is a 10 same way like ever
not every girl is a 10 but there are
guys who are socially awkward there are
guys that just don't have that game
there are a lot of guys that get missed
out because they don't have that look
that women are looking for or they don't
have that Alpha that women are looking
for I think and there's people who do it
for religious purpose as well what but I
promise you these guys they're not
I promise you yeah that not even people
that wonderful marriage in that I know
there's a cup I guarantee it's not 33
and these are nice guys then you reckon
these are the nice guys yeah they won't
cheat on you I mean I mean
but that's what I say we pick
instability right we could pick the
stable guys that aren't seeing anyone
else but we pick the guys that are
seeing like that's why you guys think
that see all the guys are sexually
active because you pick the guys that
are but whatever what percent of guys do
you think are over six foot
no maybe like 30 30 percent
the guys that are over six foot that are
more active or just how many guys are
just over six foot yeah there's I mean
I'd say like I don't know like 40 50 of
men are over six foot no way where are
you looking in America no but across the
board not just UK right across the board
us UK yes I know Americans are bad
they're tall they're tall
what about what about you I said maybe
like 25 I think 25 yeah I'll go in 20 35
of 15 yeah okay fair enough okay and
these five foot two women that are
demanding a six foot plus man that is
ridiculous but it I can't like I would
get with a guy who's like still in the
five foots because I'm only five foot
five you can be five foot nine as long
as I'm in Hills and I'm not over like
five seven even is fine for you yeah but
I think everyone's allowed to have a
preference of height like yeah you can
have the preference but there's not
enough to go around you can find one I
didn't yeah I didn't say it was a bad
thing like I mean I mean historically we
needed a guy that could protect us stay
single or just we'll wait for the you
know the six foot something guide but
listen there's only 15 of these men
though over six foot and you're telling
me all the five foot tears want to be
taking them but is this short girls are
the ones that go for the exercise and
what percent of those guys have good
jobs
and what percent of those guys are good
looking too so it's like typically if
you select a guy he's had to meet
multiple metrics and it's a very small
percentage of men that most women are
after you guys get the Raw Deal
they really do no those guys do yeah
those are yeah those guys the other ones
they've got they've got their pick
haven't they they've got their picks
yeah those guys do but then you have one
out of three men that are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year I
love that I I'm quite survive with all
these men come on get started dating
site please
go look at the guy working behind the
counter oh it's true I mean there's a
million you don't really notice it but
there's a million men that like we just
like don't see they feel invisible then
these guys if they're not getting picked
for the fact that they're meeting these
metrics yeah
um I mean you've heard like six foot six
figures six six pack I don't think
there's many what percentage many got a
six-pack not many I also got dad bods
even when they're not dads but there's
like a thing which a lot of girls like
Dad wants yeah
that's the question
when you say mum board what do you mean
like the oh the one that's had a baby
yeah you know I've had three I mean
thankfully I'm not too in a state but
honestly like you know women have had
children men almost expect us to look
like we've never had children literally
you know I don't think they expect that
a lot of them do oh they do I think they
want you to keep in shape regardless if
you have children I think that that's a
pressure that we put on ourselves to do
that I think there are a lot that don't
expect that actually or I just know some
really kind men and really good men I
feel like guys expect you to gain like
10 20 pounds what I don't think they
expect is for you to blow up like a
balloon and look like an entirely
different person yeah sure yeah you know
I think most guys are forgiving 10 20
pounds but it's just like when you look
like a completely different person yeah
you know it's like after you have a baby
I've heard like that's when men are most
likely like to step out on you because
you can't have sex for a certain amount
of months after you give birth you
obviously gonna look different your
body's change like your whole body is
different so it's like if the guy is not
really like I don't know if I don't
think he's got that energy he's going to
be up all night with a baby he ain't got
energy to be doing that in those first
six weeks these men find their energies
I also think what percent of men can't
even get laid like you have to
understand it's such a small percentage
of men that even have girls come into
them like that to the point that they
can cheat it's maybe 10 15 20 like it's
hard it's hard harder than you think for
a guy to get laid I think I think that
we think it's easier but it is just the
guys that women are choosing it's easier
for women to get that side of things I'd
imagine wasn't it really a woman can go
on a night out quite easy for her to go
around with her fella anyone she wants
really
it's true it's so true yeah
um okay do you guys think that
women romanticize toxic relationships oh
yes they do yeah I think you remember
what I said earlier about having someone
who's not necessarily a good person but
they are only good to you I can't like
there's a certain kind of appeal to
people like that and I feel like again
with the whole like oh I don't know you
can't do this you can't do that
sometimes it feels good to hear but
sometimes it's just a bit of a mistake
you know that sounds controlling I don't
like this song I know but it's like
obviously now I wouldn't but my younger
self would be like oh so this guy really
cares like enough to tell me ABCD if
that makes sense to you I and I'm not
trying to offend you here but I feel
like women that that like that often
don't have that good relationship with
their father so they're almost looking
for that father sort of authority figure
you know I think that's what that plays
into
oh also I feel like um social media has
a big part to play in that because I've
noticed a trend where on social media
will say oh um this is what women are
into now and then I'll look around me
and a few females around me and that's
what they're into and I've like I said
earlier I think there's a way for um a
man to be authoritative and all these
kind of things but what is portrayed on
social media and even the music and
everything
um is that a man must be um toxically
masculine and then that's why it's
romanticized is because everyone's like
oh um everyone around me is
romanticizing this so it must be the
right thing it must mean
um whatever they're saying that it means
sort of thing do you know I mean what is
toxic masculinity
um so I feel like it stems from a man
who does not know himself and he does
not know how to regulate his emotions
because men are very logical by the end
of the day they still have emotions and
they do not know how to regulate that
but they know what do you mean they
don't know how to regulate it okay so a
man knows innately in my opinion that
he's meant to protect and provide and
that he is meant to be at the head in
some kind of way I feel like that's an
innate thing that a man knows however
when um you are told that that is the
only thing that you must be and then
you're kind of
um other emotions emotions that make you
human are kind of shunned you do not
really mean by emotions that make you
human because um because anything like
what emotion like um to be overtly happy
or when you said when you said the word
simp like to feel like an emotion that
is like oh I want to feel soft for this
person and all these kind of things
being soft like everything is Yin and
Yang in men and women they both have
masculine feminine energy and you need
to embrace both of those but not
obviously too much masculinity in a
female and too much femininity right you
think you're asking men to emote like
women no no no I'm not saying that at
all what I'm saying is that you have to
understand that there as a as a man
you're going to have a little bit of
feminine energy even if it's one percent
twenty percent thirty percent I don't
know do you want men with a lot of
feminine energy and keep I said one
percent twenty percent I'm giving
variables and to be honest I don't mind
as long as you are able to fulfill your
role as a man which is to provide and
protect and to leave eat if you have
feminine energy if you're going to sit
there and I want to be I want to do some
damn feminine [__] with you and you're
going to sit there and allow me to do it
you can do that behind closed doors if I
want to do your nails and do your hair
and do your makeup we can do that behind
closed doors and that is makeup yes I'm
sorry we can do that behind clothes some
men will not allow that no mine yeah but
this is the thing if you and I feel like
that shows what is what is toxic
masculine okay
can I have a specific example okay so
for example um a man feels um angry
because a woman is undermining his
authority but he's not putting out that
Authority in the correct way so then he
um unleashes the anger out on her and
starts blaming her and all these kind of
things being like oh you don't listen
Okay let me give a specific example I
believe that um a man should make sure
that his woman looks presentable I do
not want to go out any people can have
their um own opinions but I don't want
to go out looking too promiscuous so if
my man says you know what I'd prefer you
to not wear that and then a woman goes
um and says you know actually I want to
wear this for example um I might wear a
top that shows a little bit of my boobs
and then my man's like I don't want to
wear that and I'm like actually you know
what um can I pull it up a little bit
and then it's okay and then if he's
toxic he'll he'll start getting angry
like oh you're undermining me so on and
so forth and it will turn into a big
argument that it does not have to be
however if he knows how to go about it
in the correct way then we might have a
little conversation about it and I would
come to some sort of compromise or he
knows how to deal with my emotions as a
man do you think that men want to have
conversations about problems or women
want to have conversations about
problems at the end of the day men and
women are two very different creatures
yeah I'm a men or women both women both
in both for different topics mostly is
women because we have a lot more
emotional issues no matter what you
think don't you think you're asking him
to emote like a woman like because often
when I hear this this is just what I've
noticed is when women say the word toxic
masculinity masculinity they're asking
men to be women it's the fact that in a
relationship you have to be able to
compromise empathize to be able to
understand stand you from your point of
view of things you have to be able to
understand me too if I need you to come
down on a level where I'm able to
actually tell you how I feel and I want
you to actually kind of understand what
I'm trying to tell you without fighting
back that's what I appreciate I mean
part of femininity is listening to your
man so is it toxically feminine if
you're not listening no I think yes I
think it is because at the same time
like like I just said you need to be
able to compromise I need to be able to
come to your level you need to be able
to come to mind and that's how the
relationship should work you should be
able to if I want to sit down and tell
you I don't like this you should be able
to hear it if you want to come and sit
down and tell me you don't like this I
should be able to hear it end off I
think that men are okay with us coming
to talk about problems but it's the way
we approach it a lot of the time we
approach it by criticizing blaming
shaming at trying to control them I
think if we're able to remove all of
that and we're able to have
conversations as a kind of coming in at
a different angle in in a respectful way
men are very happy to be having these
conversations in order to you know
ensure that the relationship is on track
I'm just I'm just curious I'm just gonna
do a pull quick with the guys
do you guys want to have a conversation
with your woman about what she wears
every time you go out
laughs
foreign
then but the thing is
it's just a conversation at the end of
the day it's not anything more than that
which is fine but it's just going back
to the toxic masculinity it's like
you're asking men to be women when it
happens everywhere when you're asking
men to emote like women so to have a
conversation like it's toxically
masculine if you don't want to have a
conversation but the thing is they can
have a conversation without crying
without doing this just listen just
listen to what I have to say I'm not
asking you to be a woman I'm not asking
you to have a period every month no I'm
not I'm saying when you say it's
toxically masculine for you not to want
to have a conversation it's like when
they say something and they want to say
that's the end of conversation you get
it like this guy can come to you and say
I don't know for example like going back
to the clothes thing I don't like what
you're wearing I can try to tell you
like oh but but no that's it he's not
even trying to hear your side of the
story and that's toxically masculine I
think so because it's like you're
toxically if that's a word like
establishing your dominance in a way
where you're not even trying to let me
talk you're trying to do this all like
just be quiet I'm your man kind of thing
I think that's what toxic message I
think that's just masculinity I think
like women just don't like being told no
no because I feel like you can be
masculine like she said before and come
in a correct way and you can tell me
babe like I'm not gonna lie to you I
don't like the way you're wearing this I
feel like this like at least here sorry
at least hear me out from my right so
that's how women would communicate
that's what I think that's how two
adults should communicate exactly no but
that's because you're trying to make men
communicate like women like have you
heard have you ever been in a men's
locker room and listen to how they talk
to each other and you're like oh oh I
can't believe that like I used to work
at a plumbing tech company and they
would just roast the [__] out of each
other and I could I could not believe
they talked to each other like that but
saying oh but like that's Community they
need to remember we are women and we our
feelings do get hurt very quick so just
be aware so you wouldn't talk to you not
referring to women as children this is
just an example you would talk to a
child a certain way because you know
it's a kid you would talk to like a
bunch of boys a certain way because you
know you're in a group of a bunch of
boys just be aware of who you're talking
to that's it and and I agree with you I
think man yeah I think men know that
they know they can't communicate to us
the same way they communicate to other
men I'm saying it's not toxically
masculine it just says no under
conversation I think it is because like
it's I think just give your reason just
give your reason because that's just
what we want give your reason babe why
you don't want me to him okay this this
and this okay yeah I understand you I'll
take it off do you do you think most
women that's their answer when when he
says when you give them a reason he
gives you a reason that they're like oh
okay no no it will go into a
conversation I feel like the clothing
um example has messed things up let me
give you another one okay so say for
example cool I live with my boyfriend
whatever like I'm the one who will
um who will be cooking that night say
for example I say babe
um I'm thinking about making ABCD for
dinner and he goes no oh you're not
doing that I feel like why is it that
you have the right to tell us what we're
eating I'm the one that's doing this
because he doesn't want to know sorry
I'm so sorry but I've been itching I
just didn't want to interrupt anybody
it's because he doesn't want to know and
know the internet in my opinion he
doesn't want to know the ins and outs
and what you've decided just cook the
food men don't want to have to have a
conversation I like to I I think men
operate from a place of like solution if
there's a problem what is the solution
how do we fix this very black and white
it's women that want to have the
conversation so instead of the I'm
cooking tonight oh babe this is what I'm
gonna cook he doesn't care
what about the rest of my chicken this
guy told me he wants fish are my
chickens left foreign
uh could you re-explain I just didn't
understand what you were saying no what
I was basically trying to say is like um
what I was saying is that's the toxic
side of the whole toxic masculinity
thing is when he wants to that apply
himself in a way where he's not trying
to hear anything else that's basically
we're just trying to be cruel I mean it
just sounds cruel like someone you say
you're going to make sure this is an
example don't worry
I don't understand the situation Oh you
mean he's undermining you how is he yeah
that's what I kind of mean like that's
what I take from that from toxicity do
you offer something and he tells you no
like you send the food away because I've
heard situations like that right where
it feels bad put it in the bin and just
don't want to eat it what if it was bad
so say I just think that's like
toxically masculine narcissistic that's
a bit far I think the word narcissistic
gets thrown around way too quick and
easy personally I do think that you know
people don't they're not most of us are
not psychologists and we can't just
label someone a narcissist because of a
behavior which we think they're not
considered bring our feelings uh
personally I use that word very seldom I
feel like when I when I touched on toxic
masculinity it got bit misconstrued
because I didn't say not having a
conversation was toxic I mean like
exerting your dominance because a woman
is um should be subservient in a lot of
different ways and I feel like um a
certain your dominance in a way that
makes her feel
um unheard
um or just like
I'm not scared scared is too much of a
word but do you understand what I'm
saying like she can't can't be heard so
if you're so dominant that she doesn't
feel heard that's toxically masculine a
man's role as well as to provide and
protect us make a woman feel safe to do
her woman injuries if she don't feel
safe that is being toxically don't you
think I'm going to change how they feel
every day
like one way I mean we all have a friend
one day she's with her boyfriend the
next day she hates him but what's her
boyfriend she's in love with him what's
she what's she doing to contribute to
the situation but we have a lot of
things going on inside like we have a
period every month that does a lot but
you know what I think you don't always
have to act on your emotions you know
you could just have the emotion yeah you
don't mean you've got to always act upon
it and I think that's where we're very
destructive when we when we're very
impulsive the moment we feel something
we thought we have to act on it you know
just sometimes ride it out just wait to
see if that feeling change if another
feeling could come and most time it will
I feel I feel like sorry just to say one
last thing I feel like I'm feeling safe
in a situation
um is something that varies like as you
said earlier love varies and all these
kind of things but for example no
relationship is perfect you're gonna
have arguments you're gonna have times
where you're like oh I hate him same
thing the way you said that our parents
might have that but if the overall
Ambiance is safety and all these kind of
things like variance is allowable we're
all humans at the end of the day I don't
even what did you say I don't even
understand what you just said oh my gosh
um
I was just touching on the fact that um
you said
[Music]
um
I remember oh no
I was just I was just talking about I
think you said um women change how they
feel all the time and I said that um
something like stability and safety is a
relationship is going to have variance
but stability and safety is not
something that um unless you have like a
really abusive um person or something
like that that is a basis of the
relationship and the ups and downs is
just what happens in that safe space
yeah but I think women don't even want
stability and when it comes to safety if
he's not abusing you
you're safe just because you feel like
safety is not just that safety is um
emotional safety being knowing that you
can go and have a conversation with your
man and he's going to um listen to what
you're saying and all these kind of
things safety comes in many different
forms and the women who don't want
stability yeah it's like men aren't here
to listen to our problems but you're
building a future with that okay why are
you always going to your goals to say if
there's two men that have a problem with
each other right
what would they do
two grown men have a problem with each
other about something what would they do
um I mean it depends they might fight
what do you think oh so you think
they're just gonna punch each other in
the face straight away they would have a
conversation it's not just females it's
just grown adults generally if you're
gonna be grown I know I want stability
so bad I do because I I literally see
that as happiness yeah and I think like
women say that but then when we a lot of
times when we talk about our exes like
we're with the ones that are the most
unstable for the longest so it's like do
I watch but that's why they're relaxed
do I watch it what we say as women or do
I watch what we do because I know I
definitely do
want stability and my ex isn't and I was
very young as well but that's all I
don't I don't know I'm not talking about
you personally I'm talking about I'm
talking about women in general yeah we
don't we don't pick stability but we
don't know every single woman mostly
done Financial stability is the main
stability that there really would go for
uh but in regards to a guy that's kind
of
I think no one one wants a walkover
that's the thing you don't want a guy
that you can control yeah I don't think
that that that's not um I don't think
that that isn't stable like I would say
my uh my Gentleman friend that's in the
cart currently uh he's very stable and I
would only know I would only know that I
am
I would only
I learned for I've you know I learned a
lot from my previous relationship and I
spent a lot of time on my own so from
that I know I don't want anymore and
this guy is super stable and somebody
might call it boring but I like it yeah
but I think that's like men kind of see
that as a problem because like in our
youth when we have the most of what men
value we pick the bad boys and you know
when we're older and we have kids then
we say oh now I want a stable guy yeah I
think that I think that that's really
tricky and for me
um I I mean you know I'm 35 I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm a spring chicken
perhaps but I'm definitely in my Prime
maybe not like from a biological
standpoint in my Prime because you know
I got maybe like like a year left before
before whatever
um but I feel more I feel great I feel
small my most sexy I feel my most
confident I feel my you know I feel like
I've really and I mean you look great
but it's still not but it's still not
what men value because men men value
Youth and they value Purity yeah for
sure and it's just when you're older you
can't offer that anymore so it's like
when we have the most to offer we pick
the most unstable guys yeah yeah or
we're already sucked into that with the
most yeah and it's not it's not just you
know this panel like I did Street inner
I do Street interviews all the time and
that's always what people say around 30
that's when they switch from the the bad
boys to the stable guys do you think
that women feel like they can save men
like they feel like they can fix him I
think women okay why do we watch the
Kardashians and not the NBA
watching drama
do you yeah but I don't personally like
it in my life it gives me headaches yeah
yeah because I I don't know I definitely
don't want any drama I've I've never
really wanted drama but yeah I don't
know what you say or watch what you do
right so who do we pick well that's it I
don't watch soap operas and again I
think even when people watch soap operas
all the time sometimes you end up not
realizing but kind of playing out your
own kind of soap opera you know because
you have that kind of mindset of that is
how life is but and yeah there is that
there is that fine line I suppose
between stability and boredom like me I
am a person that enjoys spontaneity and
not like a routine that's one of the
reasons why I work for myself because I
don't like just like this you know same
time working every day like this mundane
kind of reality so I do think that it is
important to kind of find someone that's
also willing to kind of not just be that
you know very routine everything the
same because that that does become
boring
um I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second
um okay sleep is the cousin of death
also guys all super chats will be read
today so if you have something that you
want to say a question you want me to
ask put it in the chat and I will read
it um okay sleep is the cousin of death
children dating grown men what am I
listening to I don't know this is a
first for me I've never had this many
under
stories on the on a panel Victor um I
keep hearing I felt manipulated it makes
me wonder why do they avoid taking
responsibility they choose men they know
how what they are how can they improve
if they never take responsibility um
tell 92.65
love is definitely a choice love lust is
what most people feel and consume with
love because Disney movies and romance
novels have the Lines Blurred um Chief
Keef a feeling is a signal is a signal
for you to pay attention there are
emotions tied to it it's a filter in
which it's being seen through pause and
Center Yourself by a stoic rational and
logical person to get you through I'm 90
Frito pie if a female is nine foot I
would still date a rod a hundred dollar
Super Chat
um Rod I'm six for 230 pounds and a
self-made millionaire how rare how rare
am I
probably like half a percent you'd
probably be very rare
um Shaq bellfield um you can lead them
to water but you can't make them drink
I'm 90 free toe pie why are you why is a
fish telling a shark how to be a shark
The Savvy ninja um you have to you have
to talk about things at times a man
can't expect a woman to never question a
suggestion he made um women are not our
servants H Vargas 207 a toxically
masculine fireman a toxically masculine
fireman will run into a building on fire
and save you 90 free topai why do men
have to step out down why can't women
level up 90 free to pie women hate the
truth and context period
zero Fallout one we don't care what you
do but there will be consequence of
choices men might be losing now but but
it's women who will lose in the long run
there's only a 20 percent of highly
attractive men regular men are waking up
to the Raw Deal DMACC um listening to
these women I want to stay alone forever
they don't understand men for the panel
of
um oh I can ask that question in a
second let me just refresh and just make
sure there aren't any more
um okay zero Fallout the problem with
women is they marry the stable guy after
they get ran through and destroy their
lives we all know over five bodies is a
high likelihood of dissatisfaction in
marriage King James 313 um if we have to
validate our opinions on what to cook or
where then our opinions actually mad oh
wait if we have to validate our opinions
on what to cook or to wear then do our
opinions actually matter enough to have
a discussion about 90 free-toe pie so
um the next question
that he submitted is who takes criticism
easier men or women
I feel like men take it easy yeah
because women take things so personally
I think a lot of emotions and men don't
like racism
you think men take criticism worse than
women
I think they could probably take it in a
in a work sense but in a relationship
sense I don't think they're taking it I
feel like they'll take it better from
other men than from women I mean I don't
really think it matters who it's coming
from like if you I don't know if if
you've got a couple and a woman says
baby come you need to go to the gym you
know like you're putting you're getting
a little winter weight honey you know it
makes a little joke about it he will go
to the gym if you tell a woman she's
putting on weight what what then happens
I think the problem is in a relationship
sense is women are very quick to
criticize but not quick enough to praise
and then therefore that's what gets
men's backs up it's kind of like you
know I do all these good things but you
will point out that one bad thing that I
do and you will
do you think that women are never
satisfied
I think it depends on the woman
some women are what we're talking about
in general I think women are always
looking for improvements yeah men are
quite easily pleased whereas I think
women are always looking for some way to
improve the situation yeah there's
something extra I also thought one of
the comments was really interesting
about um the whole fairy tale thing and
I think so like my mind went to the
whole you know as young girls we grew up
on Disney we know about the prince
charming and this is this and this kind
of sets our ideology as far as our
husband or what we want from a man
flip that on its head I'm not too sure
if it's like that in the States but in
the UK there's this thing of I don't
know if anyone remembers being in
primary school you know if a boy pushed
you over or teased you or was horrible
to you it meant that he did that because
he fancied you and I feel like somewhere
along the lines as we've grown up and as
we've become women there is this oh if
he's being mean to me if he's ignoring
me obviously it makes you want to chase
them more because so maybe
psychologically you feel like he wants
you and that's why he's being mean to
you it's really trippy but I I find it a
lot what in some what incentive do men
have to be nice to women then well I
mean I don't I don't feel like there is
an incentive to be nice to him and I
feel like you should just be nice to
women exactly the same way as women
should just be nice and respectful to
like as people we should just be nice
and respectful to each other but you
know the problem with that nice guys
finish last but women choose that for it
to be that way if that makes sense so as
you said earlier like the whole
accountability thing I'm not saying that
men don't play a part in the way that a
woman feel tools but we do have to be
accountable and responsible for our own
emotions and for our own decisions that
we make you know someone else in the
Super Chat mentioned about
um
uh it just went from my mind now but
about women not understanding men and I
can kind of appreciate that to some
degree I like to think I do understand
men to a certain degree but that's only
men that I've engaged with the men that
I've come across we operate from a
completely different mental and we're
very different as human beings and I
said it last time you know men and women
do complement each other we're not the
same and I think that there's a lot of
responding and not enough listening yeah
yeah I think what you said about nice
guys finish and last like it's actually
so true because you know that as a woman
you've probably got like so many guys
that are like shouting you and doing all
of these things but you've got that one
guy that that's not shouting you like
that you're just thinking that and I got
a nice guy yeah we friend zoned them all
I know literally and you've got like so
many people in your DMs you've got
people in your Snapchat these are all
nice guys you're not really looking at
them the future husband is probably in
the friend zone
I don't know about that
that's what they say if you want to know
what your level is look at your friend
zone yeah my friend zone of males
especially trash bags oh wow
wait why do you why would you surround
yourself with trash bags now do you know
why I actually appreciate my male
friends the ones that are trashed the
most because they teach me what to look
out for and guys like they literally
show me but they're sitting on the sub
bench you know they're waiting for the
opportunity nah not all of them also
there's someone that's not waiting for
the opportunity I'm talking about
friends like actual Family Guy friends
they don't want to sleep with you you
don't think they will sleep with you if
you give them a window I was naive to
that when I was younger and I realized
you know what no opportunity
I
[Laughter]
can do it okay so this is what I I want
you to do I want you to call him put it
on speaker okay let's see if he even
picks up if anyone okay if anyone
everyone be quiet put on speaker and say
that
so say that it's late and you're horny
and you want them to come over I am not
saying no no I feel like you can I can
say look I I know that this is so Random
like don't judge me but it's late like
I'm really horny I need a cuddle tonight
you're gonna tell it was not true
afterwards anyway it doesn't matter yeah
he'll see it on the stream you can show
him or even if you were to say you were
a bit tipsy can I come over he wouldn't
he would never do it that's what you
said yeah right so you don't need to
worry I'm not saying the horny part I'm
gonna say I'm tipsy let me come over
yeah one second but I want to like I
want to be picked up first but you need
to allude to the fact that you want to
have sex with him and see if he'll have
sex with you let's see if he picks up
though I know this guy okay
Chris
hey how are you I'm good how are you man
I'm good
I'm in school right now oh really are
you gonna be home in a bit
well this is food yeah no I mean I'm the
ocean right now oh really why are we
there yeah
when are you gonna be back
um where are you slow I'm gonna be later
um I can get home for you I can't lie
let me see you
yeah yeah I know I know I know I know
foreign
[Music]
I was just thinking
why haven't we ever dated or why haven't
we ever hooked up yeah yeah
because people come over and chill just
exactly you know hello hey quick
question
serious
well I hope you never did like why have
you never like spoken of him
huh well we never spoken often
yeah
I mean like that
yeah like that like that
oh I'm asking you
no but that's probably what team it was
literally children back then though
the alcohol
is it
I call my shot you know
100 he will smash if
he's skipping through the streets right
now do you still think men and women can
be friends yeah I would call another one
hold them
I actually unless they're gay I don't
think they can now I might show you
right now hold on but I feel like you
need to be a bit more direct with it
though I have faith hey that one's a bit
too late
how many of these men have you gone I'm
telling you like I've got male friends
but it's like I've known a lot of these
a lot that I'm very close to I've known
them from my childhood and you think
you're one of the boys
pretty much yeah
I've been doing whatever I see them I
help them link girls and stuff so it's
like oh my gosh yeah I've heard this
like so much and I've always been like
yeah you could be friends with like boys
but I've just loved from experience you
actually cannot no I think you can when
there's not an attraction if there's no
attraction there but he's probably
attracted this is the thing it's always
girls who just are like no what percent
of guys male or female friends are like
severely overweight
huh as in female friends that way yeah
like when a guy has a female friend if
she's severely overweight what percent
they're always attractive
um
I actually I'm not too sure on that one
I don't know I'm still struggling to be
to get what you mean I mean
guys guys usually pick women to be
friends with and they are attractive
women so you're saying that guys only
pick friends that they're attracted to
that they consider attractive in some
way or that the only connection of like
you guys initially sparking up a
conversation would be based on oh let me
go chat to her unless you're like
neighbors and you've grown up together I
guess the real question is can you be
friends with a guy then he wouldn't
sleep with you
I'm not doing that again
I I want to say yeah the I really want
to say yeah you can but I don't think so
I think if you're a try if you're an
attractive woman and you've got
substance about you even forget the
substance if you're an attractive woman
if you really wanted to you could sleep
with any of your friends whereas we're
the ones who say I don't want to cross
that line you know we're such good
friends
you're what 21 yeah yeah you'll learn
any of them you're attractive woman any
of any of them yeah trust me yeah I
haven't
don't think I've I can't think anything
right now but I think I like to think if
I wanted to sleep with any of my male
friends I probably could
if I put it on them like that I could
not that I want to I just had to clarify
my friends are my friends
there's none there's none sweetheart
it's all right you got you got somewhere
I mean look it well we'll take the
contact
hold on
no
here's my most platonic friend let me
think oh that's risky
now because that one the friendship will
end if it gets sour no they'll see
afterwards anyway this is just for the
for the sake of the out of the point
that we're trying to prove here yeah
they'll see it you could just send them
the link yeah I was just joshing I was
just kidding should I okay do it ah I'm
here for all of this
nah that's p no that one's Pig you know
the one I've been calling brother for
years I don't need that because if that
goes left that's getting blocked we
should just see yeah just see because
you're confident that he won't write
he's your friend
are you sure I find this crazy as well
but it's actually I literally don't
think you can be friends with straight
males like
attraction if you're attractive then
that's it it would the man will rise for
the occasion I mean you can't yeah you
can't be friends with them without them
wanting to sleep with you that's scary
and they will only sleep with you if you
allow them to if you say no forever then
they won't as simple as that would
do you think then it's disrespectful to
have male friends in a relationship
oh maybe like if you're like
acquaintances not ready but if they're
like friends and they're over absolutely
because how would you feel if the roles
were reversed and he had a bunch of
girls wanting to sleep with him all the
time I would but the thing is until just
now I didn't know that
oh my God
I can't lie I feel like with this guy
here I've been I've hooked him up with
people like I've been friends with some
of his girls and that like I've been
tight with this girl so I never actually
thought in my head it was that loud
would you would you date him no
just telling him a dream right there see
this is the thing I think I think if you
have a male friend who thinks that he
could sleep with you then no
that that's not a healthy situation no I
mean no you know come on we know what if
one of the roles were reversed and your
boyfriend had a girl yeah if if he ever
said yes like she would be down 100
however he's told her now are you cool
with that no I know she's like no that's
actually happened with my boyfriend he's
told me like a friend of his wanted to
sleep with him and he said no but I
remember she was there when we went out
on a night out and
she was all over him as well and it was
just a lot like I couldn't stand it it
wasn't a thing it's not a thing it's
nothing yeah yeah yeah is it different
do you think though when you're like I'm
just trying to think because I have got
a couple of male friends I've got male
friends
that's why I can't get over how red I
look I've never wearing red again or
something like this um
um but I think when you're both like in
a relationship say he's married and I'm
married I think maybe that's different
because I prefer it because I've had
actually an example of a male friend
um and we were really good friends and
it just got to a point where I mean he
did Express that he felt something in
that sense towards me and it obviously
made it awkward because I was also
friends with his wife
um and I kind of just said he said that
while he was married yeah wow he did a
Pamela so we've not we've we've kind of
cut the contact now but you know I kind
of said before actually do you know what
in the situation before he said that we
can't just be friends you and I it's
either like we're friends as couples or
not at all kind of thing and he didn't
want to be friends as couples because he
actually felt uncomfortable with me
around his wife because he felt an
attraction towards me so that kind of
messed up the Friendship there so I
think that yeah it's I think it's okay
like if you're friends of a guy but he's
got a wife and you're friends with a
wife and he's friends with your husband
like that sort of thing now as a woman I
feel like
to make the other women comfortable like
you always just need to make ties with
her like even with my friend with his
girls like I've always been that girl
who's like all that hey like if we're
chilling together like say we had a
drink up or something I'm gonna go to
her I'm gonna chill with her yeah I'm
gonna see how she's doing like leave him
for a second it's a respect thing yeah
it's a respect that look I'm not I'm not
a threat to you exactly I want you to
know that I'm not a threat to you and I
think I think if if your friend who you
friend zone let's say for example yeah
okay if I gave you a window you would
jump through the window but understand
I'm never giving you a window so if you
are happy to settle for that then that's
up to you that's your decision you have
to be accountable for that
um and you have to respect me and my
partner and if there's any tinge of
disrespect you've got to go yeah I agree
as long as that person is because I feel
like some guys will try to slightly just
like throw shade on your mind at the
moment that happens it's like no we
can't be friends but also it makes me
think like
but they just sleep with you because say
they would sleep with anyone who's like
attractive and so if you come on to them
why would they say no if you're a friend
or not because they would sleep with
someone who's attractive who they don't
know who that you know what maybe it's
not just because sometimes conflict with
someone who's not attractive maybe it's
not just because you're friends with
them but if they've never seen you like
that and then you turn to them and say
that to them why would they turn it down
because they they would do it on a night
out anyway I feel like that's a little
bit naive I think I think I think
obviously men are very visual in my
opinion men are visual creatures right
they are visual and if you look good
then you know it's potential blood can
be rushed into places but ultimately you
look good and they acknowledge that you
look good but if you couple that
especially in today's society where
substance is so dwindled if you know
what I mean women some women tend to not
have any substance or any depth to them
so if they're your friend you're already
cool so that's one element you probably
got a good head on your shoulders which
is another element there are there are
things about you that they know that
probably are more attractive if that
makes sense because I don't need all
that just to sleep with you though no
they don't but but then they wouldn't
need to but why why are they maybe not
why they yeah why are they friends with
you there's a reason why your friends
you have a connection
are we best friends or are we just
friends I'm friends with a lot of people
so it doesn't have to be on like a deep
but it depends on level yeah sorry I
didn't mean to cut you so but then I
guess I don't know for me I I the friend
I don't use the term friend Loosely you
can be an associate that's okay you can
be a colleague that's okay you can be
just somebody who I know in passing
that's okay if I call you a friend we're
deeper level than that you can come to
my home you can be around my kids you
can be around my partner that's okay an
associate you can't come into my house
as an associate because there's
different levels to it but I have heard
uh should I say like friend boys online
or like acquaintances of mine say they
started talking to a long-term friend of
theirs like in a different way and then
they would be like funny I've never
looked at her that way I've heard that
before
I have no I know at the moment the
moment she says come over I'm a bit
Randy
it didn't happen like that it didn't it
started like with them did they end up
hooking up yeah ended up being a
boyfriend and girlfriend oh so you know
then he did look at her like that but
not at the beginning exactly I think
that what she's I agree with what she's
saying because it's like
at the end of the day you can be in a
relationship with someone or you can end
up getting with someone that you've been
friends with but it would not have
started off like that like they could
have seen you in a whole different light
but until you actually put it out there
they didn't think twice about it like
before it would have been like oh yeah
this is my boy well I'm with my partner
we were friends for several years before
we got together and I did ask him you
know did you ever look at me that way
type of thing and he will say well no
because I was in a relationship and he
always tried to keep himself looking on
his good behavior in that sense but the
more and more I delve like yeah but did
you ever find me attractive whatever
then obviously he will go well yeah
obviously I found you attractive I think
it's more like maybe he didn't see an
opportunity yeah and then she gave him
signals so do you guys think that every
single male in your life that you're not
related to has looked at you like that
yeah maybe I mean whether they have or
whether they haven't if you offer it up
they're gonna take it [__] but what if
they don't no but they would
but
well it's funny too because if you ask
guys about this
like they'll tell you like they know how
like if you ever heard a guy say I know
how men think yeah
[Music]
um I'm gonna Read Super chats and then
we're gonna watch a video
um okay
bodybuilding lifestyle my best friend
slept with my girlfriend it's a no
Carlos X most men have low standards for
one base home run don't flatter yourself
most of your guy friends can get busy
and go right back to the Ball Game black
is Panther
um those those call her friends is
exactly what we're talking about dudes
do not talk to their male friends like
that dudes were talking to her men code
switch because women can't handle the
truth LP Berkshire um Pearl is the goat
um Chief Keef I mean that's why women
deserved last Myron gains
um Pearl I asked what parent takes
criticism what parent takes criticism
better zero Fallout one the problem is
women go on to marry the stable I read
that one already uh blessing can we
watch the video
please
relationship like now with Tommy are you
are you in touch with him at all or uh
do you just kind of I mean text here and
there you know nothing nothing too crazy
I mean he's married and and happy and
she's good to him and I I totally
support that and think and think that's
great so I mean I hate to be annoying
and going through this again and for
sure she's annoyed but
um I respect their relationship and just
glad he's happy and he has somebody in
his life do your boys like him or are
they estranged they do they like him no
they they see him all the time I see him
all the time and I think that this movie
too is kind of like a love letter to
their parents they know they come from
True Love they want people to see the
real story and I thought that was kind
of cute and kind of charming and and
really you know Brandon um is very
artistic and really wanted to show the
story from
it was really it was really well done
and and I enjoyed it sometimes I I found
myself going I wonder if I said to Pam
well do you have any regrets like do you
think there were certain things in life
or would you just do it all over the
same exact way it was it was it a fun
ride or was there there was there was a
tragic or miserable what how do you
assess it it was all of it but it was
more good times than bad and
um
yeah I wouldn't do it any other way I
mean I just feel like it was just this
wild wild ride and I made it home in one
piece I came back to the place I grew up
in I bought the house of my grandmother
and I'm living in it and I'm looking at
my life from the same place my feet
touched the ground when I was a baby I
mean I'm right I look at it all like a
movie
do you think women learn from their
mistakes typically
maybe they have to be repeated again and
again to learn I think I think they
learn eventually yeah it's difficult to
learn things from the first time of
making a mistake I think so I think it
depends on the woman I'm sorry I don't
mean to tell you I think it depends on
the woman and why she is in a in a life
probably not but there are some who do
but in general you would say no I mean I
can only for me I learn but in general I
probably think no no what do you think
most women are in a vicious cycle maybe
who never ends yeah
they're chasing something what do you
guys think do you think in general women
learn from their mistakes or no like I
said eventually but it takes a little it
takes a while to get how many how many
times
let's say on average maybe three
three times for how many years oh how
many months I'd say three times with the
person like I feel like in terms of
learning yeah I feel like in terms of
learning your mistakes as well it comes
into growing up and your age and stuff
like the same chances I would have given
someone I don't know a few years ago I
wouldn't give them no like that would
take me longer to learn I mean take me
quicker to learn than it would have
before if that makes sense what do you
think
um yeah I think it definitely depends on
where you are in your stage of growth
and what you have experienced before and
how you've um reflected on that
do you think men should date women that
have dated bad boys in the past
men should date women do you think would
you do you think that men should date
women that have dated bad boys in the
past why not I think they might have an
attitude women who date Bad Boys in
first well I don't have it I think I'm
talking about you we're talking about in
general I think that there were pros and
cons to it I think from for a man who
has dated for a man who dates a woman
who has dated a bad boy in the past you
would hope or you would think that she
would learn from the mistakes of the bad
boy and appreciate the good guy right
and then on the flip side of that I
guess there's a posit there is a
negative because a guy who dates a woman
who's dated a bad boy before she will
have this
trauma this trauma or she may bleed on
him when he didn't cut her if that makes
sense so I feel like there's pros and
cons too it's like almost the man of the
future have to pay for the mistakes of
her past I feel like everybody has to
pay for the mistakes of people's past if
you're not healing from it and you're
not learning from it for sure I mean I'm
sure we've all at some point had a guy
that's like trying to go through your
phone because some girl cheated on him
before do you know what I mean yeah yeah
taking your thumb and unlocking your
phone while you're sleeping yeah all of
that stuff experienced it all yeah I
think it's more high risk for a guy
obviously to get involved with a woman
that's had a bad past but a lot of men
do like to play the hero
you know what I feel like I feel like
even though sorry do you want to go so
this is save a hole
I was being polite
funny enough even though men come across
with the stronger personalities than us
I feel like when it comes to
relationships and being emotional I feel
like they are kind of more fragile in
the sense where you some women will hurt
a man and it will stay with him for his
whole life whereas with a woman even
though we do get her and it will take us
a while to get over it we're not gonna
portray that in every single situation
he talks about our exes more men or
women
women the the party we might talk about
it but their demeanor will change like
the way they act and the way they
actually carry themselves with change
because of one relationship that's what
I've seen so do you think that men are
not as resilient as women or do you
think that
that men in certain situations allow
themselves to be vulnerable allow
themselves to trust a woman and she
shits on it and that's why it hits him
just as hard yeah because he that is not
a man's default necessarily maybe they
just learn what works and what doesn't
you know men are problem solvers do you
know what I say so if they treat a woman
like a queen and she treats him like
[__] and then they realize oh if I if I
treat her worse she treats me better do
you know what I think I think I'm like
oh I'm gonna pick when it comes to
thinking I think men think with logic
women obviously you think of emotion I
feel like emotionally it's easier to
heal yourself than logically because I
feel like logically you're going to be
thinking okay so the positive woman did
this to me I need to now watch out for
this in the third one whereas where
certain women are emotional it's going
to be I don't know they're gonna be more
points to forgive if that makes sense
move on if that also makes kind of sense
yeah no it does make sense I I get where
you're coming from and I definitely
think that women you know is it's
biology women operate from you know the
emotional side and men tend to operate
from The Logical side but I think that I
don't know I'm definitely an emotional
woman I feel everything very intently
but my experiences have led me to be
very logical in my decision making right
so it's like I can sit around and I can
be upset that my relationship ended or
let's say hypothetically a guy cheated
on me right I can sit around and oh my
God but I just feel so worthless what
was it or I can okay cool look
oh all right that's not really the best
example to give but you can look at
something logically and be accountable
and forgive yourself and then you don't
need to chase the whole emotion thing if
that makes sense the whole yeah I kind
of know where I was going with it but I
don't know I hear what you're saying but
at the same time I feel like cool in the
same situation where we would be on the
emotional side of things like I said a
guy will not be logically thinking okay
so cool this guy has done this to me
now I'm gonna do this to prevent this
from happening again and now he's gonna
start building up that I love himself
that kind of wool you get it so it's
gonna be a thing where now maybe he
didn't used to act like this before but
he acts like this now because of what
he's been through but it's not
necessarily emotional not necessarily
emotional it's now kind of wired into
like a problem solver yeah it's a
problem solver so this was the problem
and this is how I'm gonna solve the
problem by not letting everyone else in
it's like I can get the youngest hottest
women by treating them like [__] because
that's what they want or that's at least
what they're alluding to what they want
yeah I think the only sorry exception to
that about talking about exes is when a
man has been divorced I think that they
do that that really plays on their mind
and that that's very difficult for them
to move past
what is one thing
that you did wrong that contributed to
your last relationship or a relationship
ending and you cannot say I just
overlooked a red flag I can take this
one okay I was a coward in my last
relationship I will own that 100 I was a
coward and I was scared and I wasn't
honest and I was
Allied and
and I think if I hadn't have been so
cowardly in the last year of our
relationship
we would have parted it wouldn't we
wouldn't have had the war that we had if
I was braver and I weren't so scared of
the repercussions
yeah okay okay I'll own that I know that
this is going to make me sound really
bad but he goes
um that one I'm not entirely sure if
this was the real reason or it was an
excuse for him but what ended up
happening was long and short of it at
the start of the relationship he cheated
on me and then he came back asking me to
marry him and then I actually said yes
and then I went back and said actually
no I don't feel like marriage is where
we're at right now and it was it
actually did become a bit of an on and
off relationship actually I said I
haven't done enough but in hindsight it
was more on and off as in breakup for a
few days and back together you know a
lot like a long period and the last time
that he came back he said to me
um like you know let's get back on
together and I said actually someone
previously that I dated had got back in
touch with me and we had arranged to
meet up for a drink and I honestly said
actually I'm not ready to get back for
you yet I've got a date in the diary
with this x um that I just actually want
to see whether or not I still feel
anything towards this person and that
was kind of a big smash to his ego and
he for him that was the final straw okay
so you saw an X while you guys were
dating no once we'd broken up and I
thought it was the end I somebody from
my past had reached out to me sorry so I
don't know so what was the what were you
what's your accountability for the
demise of your last relationship maybe
because he wanted to feel like I was the
one and only man ever for him and that I
wasn't looking at another option now but
you're talking about him what was your
accountability what do you think you did
sorry Paul okay well
by showing that I still wanted to
explore other options I guess
okay I don't know if that was wrong for
that maybe not I don't know I'm confused
because I thought that was after you
guys broke up are you ready so it was on
he kept breaking up with me and then
getting back together like a week later
okay so in between that so the time that
he actually came back and said okay
let's get back together I said well in
the interim period once you when you
broke up with me my ex got in touch and
I'm arranging to meet up with him so
before that like what do you think
contributed to him like breaking up with
you oh um insecurity because I called
off the engagement okay and he felt that
I didn't forgive him for the cheating I
guess okay oh not being able to let
things go yeah okay go ahead
okay
um what was the question again
um what is something that contributed to
your last relationship ending
um that that you did that I did yeah and
you can't say I ignored red flags oh no
that's always the go-to I think
what happened was first of all we all
know I was very young my I've only had
two boyfriends so it's this one I've got
now
and the one before
I think because I have like a real
passion for something as well and I
studied it when I was in secondary
school
obviously I had to go home because it
was long distance and FaceTime him and
it was quite a lot especially when you
have to wake up at like six in the
morning every single morning and then
train until six two and I think I
honestly
I think it was quite natural I think it
was just like I can't do this anymore
I'm also a bit young for you and I don't
know what I want also
uh if anything I just kind of wanted to
focus on what I was doing because so you
just weren't that invested in the
relationship yeah I think in the end at
the start I really was and then
I just thought also am I
like just in this to just be in this
because I did have such a deep feeling
for him but
then again I was so young to even
know what it was really I don't know
whether it was just
I Loved Someone loving me or I don't
know yeah you're only 21 or 22 yeah 21.
everyone's like she's only had two
boyfriends oh my gosh she's 21. yeah
um go ahead
oh me yeah okay
um what I can say is in my last
relationship I think that during the um
the time of my relationship I was
obviously young so I used to be like a
bit of a doormat in a way I used to kind
of let this guy get away with whatever
he wanted to and
just kind of accept things and like
Overlook a lot of things
um so when it came towards the end it
was because I've now made this thing in
the relationship where it's okay to do
what you're doing so now when I've
actually tried to come and talk back and
like try actually stand up for myself
because towards the end I felt like I
matured a bit and I knew what I kind of
wanted and when he was doing certain
things I'll tell him and then that's
when things started to kind of backfire
and when I started to see the real toxic
side of this man it's only because I had
allowed him to kind of walk on me in the
first place and not really value myself
that much in order to tell him no like
towards the end when I actually did
decide to tell him stuff like no he
wouldn't have it so your accountability
is you let him be toxic no well yes I
know like it was for more than me though
like it was me not really standing up
for myself being toxic too no so you
weren't being toxic I promise you but he
was being toxic very much and that's her
accountability no my accountability is
the fact that
like I let things go too easier
I know it's being a doormat I used to
let this guy just walk all over me like
it's nothing and I wasn't really
standing up for myself if that makes
sense so so your your accountability is
you let him be toxic well yeah
and then you repeat what I'm saying I'm
thinking it um but yeah I'm just
repeating what you said cool and less
words okay go ahead
um I feel like
and okay the way that I've been the most
toxic I guess is by
making decisions that I know how it's
gonna go and I know it's gonna go badly
for both of us
and still doing those things for
whatever reason
um it's like I could easily choose not
to but I'm just like
maybe I want to see if I still have um a
hold over this guy or what I can still
do kind of thing so I'll choose to make
that bad decision and be like and then
and halfway through the decision I'll be
like I already knew that it was gonna
play out this way so why did I do it
kind of thing
I'm sorry this is so broad I'm just
trying to understand
philosophical aren't you sorry
for example for example um we may have
had an argument and
um we're not talking for a few days and
I will be like
I know that you know maybe we should
break off the relationship but I just
want to see if I still have this hold
over this guy so I want to call him and
be like oh um let's go out and do
something and then
see if he's going to react in a way
where it's like yes and if you don't
react in a way that's yes and I'm going
to be like why because then I want to
feel like I don't have that hold over
you and that's really toxic because I
know it's really freaking toxic because
I know that um so you're waiting to
break up with him until you felt like
you had him no no no no no because it's
nothing where I didn't have him um I
would always like we we have a
connection like we've got that hold over
each other but I feel like maybe I was
being insecure or something I don't know
but when we had an argument or something
like that and I would I was thinking to
myself you know what maybe we should
break up maybe um this relationship
isn't right for us I'd be like
we've had an argument I don't know how
he now feels maybe he wants to call it
quits as well and I don't I've never had
someone break up with me so I'm always
the one that makes you sound like such a
cat but I've always been the one doing
the breaking up so if I feel like oh you
know what we've had this argument and
now you might want to break up with me I
need to make sure that's not the case by
contacting you and seeing what's up and
then if you don't want to break up with
me that's cool I still know that you
know it's all good and if I wanted to
break up with you I could
I feel like what you're saying is you
like playing the game yeah
I used I used to be a very toxic very
very toxic person and I feel like that's
why now I can sit back and be like
there's a way to go about and not
because I don't like stress no more do
you feel like men are aware of how toxic
women can be no yes and they know they
know they know oh maybe they do no I'm
telling you they know but you don't have
to change it's like you don't have to
yeah yeah but yeah but I I say these
things and I just maybe I I don't know
but I I don't know like every single man
this is why you know you know your
female friends right and you know how
they interact with their boyfriends and
yeah I'm sure you know one or two that's
toxic right do you think they're
boyfriends aware I don't think my
closest or friends any of them are toxic
because I think their aim is to not be
right I'm sure do you know a toxic girl
anywhere yeah of course of course so do
you think their boyfriends know
if they're toxic or not yeah
yeah I think maybe they just they just
ignore it put up it depends how toxic
you want to be because maybe he'll
I don't know she could be toxic on one
specific thing I can't think of one at
the top of my head but maybe that have
you ever heard of a boy that's like um I
don't know he finds it attractive when a
woman is like really gets hot-headed on
something
but you know what I mean yeah like or I
don't know
I feel you but I feel like this is why
the game is called the game because
everyone's always trying to one-up each
other but also I don't understand how
people have the energy for that I know
it's so draining because I've seen
that's one of my girls I love her Purity
can we just say like she's so like oh I
just I don't know
honestly yeah there are so many other
things you could be doing in that time
run yourself a bath don't go on Snapchat
and then like oops half swipe it and
don't reply to me now people have the
energy to put up quotes
you know the thing where people like
message each other pretend not to see it
for hours just open it and I'll just
open it I do that yeah but it's not even
me being toxic it's just me not being
asked but people are like yeah but I'm
not gonna open it yet have you guys ever
told a guy that a girl was being toxic
have you ever had to tell a guy that
like a guy friend brother yep yep hell
yeah what happened oh
to be honest I feel like
when I think about it guys kind of get
sucked in like we do because he didn't
leave her straight away he knew that she
was being toxic so he was like I know
they're not saying this I know I know I
know but it's like he didn't leave her
for a minute until he went to jail and
then he realized like all right let's go
she she was The Toxic one but he went to
jail yeah listen good people go to jail
I'm gonna tell you this before
it could be good-hearted and you can be
doing some stuff that's obviously not
the best yeah but she started doing
something illegal okay cool but
good-hearted people can do illegal stuff
at one time slavery was legal remember
that we're gonna compare that to jail
yeah
I'm just telling you like cool you can't
judge people all the time based off the
life choices that they've made or
basically what based off what life has
brought today I do I do judge people
based on I judge people based on their
personality and and the traits that they
have I think it depends on the scenario
if someone went to jail for arms robbery
I shouldn't judge him it's not just him
a little bit
okay bottom drawer are you gonna are you
gonna judge people for trying to make a
living for themselves in the world
that's not giving them an opportunity I
have no sympathy if you're born in the
west I'm sorry I know people that really
had no opportunity that are born in
third world countries that that
literally had zero opportunity so if
you're born in the west I have no
sympathy
fair enough that's your opinion to be
responsible for their their actions for
sure and be aware of the repercussions
that are going to happen but to bring it
back to the question about toxic women
um yeah for sure my brother dated a girl
and um she was very
um she was very demanding she was very
problematic she would do things to get a
reaction out of him like I don't know
they might have like a small
disagreement over like the smallest
thing and later on in the day she's
posting the subliminals and she's going
out and she's you know just all of this
triggering [__] that she knew excuse me
that she knew would get and a reaction
from him but it wasn't a positive
reaction and you know in some cases
people act out and it's like any
reaction is better than no reaction in
some cases so I think people just will
either act out but actually maturity and
that non-toxic stuff is acting in a
positive way like she could have got
he's a she could have resolved some
issues a lot easier but she chose to be
problematic that there's ways to burn
people stop burning yourself because I
know why are we burning people why don't
we just leave them no but that what I'm
trying to say is like cool for example
one of my girls I know we used to maybe
like girl or something she'll purposely
make sure she's doing something that the
guy that she's involved with is gonna
see so that he'll get mad and then when
he gets mad now they're both arguing and
it's just if you want to like if you
want him to burn just leave him they get
me just leave him alone and that's what
I think like at the end of the day if I
want someone to burn or if I want
someone to just not feel my presence no
more they're not gonna feel it they're
gonna be there on my subscribe and
they're going to be watching my story
burning but I've got no involvement you
can't message me you don't subscribe you
get it but the thing is why just not
block or just unfollow oh no because
honey I like to I like them to see what
I'm doing I feel like if you don't want
them anymore why not why no because it's
like now you know what you lost there
you go why do you care if if you if they
know what they lost I don't care if
you're done that's why I deleted them no
but I'm you're just talking about it you
just said I don't want them yeah you
just said you just wanted
you know when people say like cool the
people that hate you in life like you
want them to basically see you go far
right
yeah I don't care if they see me go far
they see me go now I don't want to see
him at all it's not a thing where you
care or not but it's like a thing where
like at the end of the day you're gonna
see me doing anything it's gonna be
something without you like you might not
care or not it's everyone's each opinion
but my opinion is I can't lie when
people because I know I've got people
who don't like me I've got people who
hate me and you can hate me from over
there I'm not gonna acknowledge you but
I know in the back of my head like you
can hate me but you're gonna see it but
I'm doing good and you're gonna see that
I'm doing okay like without you like
that's your business it don't mean I'm
gonna come message you and show you like
I am doing this I'm doing that but when
you see me here you're gonna be burning
in you and that's better than me going
back and forth with someone and me
having an altercation with someone I'd
rather them just see me doing good and
that's there you get it there we go
um no I feel like you kind of changed
what you said no but that's what I meant
you get it okay so I shouldn't believe
what you say I think that no because
sometimes when I'm saying things you
don't know what you're saying no I do
know what I'm saying I know what I'm
saying but it's like I was just
explaining what I kind of meant behind
what I said because sometimes when you
say things bluntly like it you don't
always understand anything but I'll just
explain it okay there we go I think you
were gonna say something no no I think
you you were ready to say something you
were started saying something I was just
gonna say thank you I was just gonna say
I feel like um a lot of toxic behaviors
come from ego and all these kind of
things and when you're with someone who
is exhibiting these kind of behaviors
you can kind of see their ego seeping
out in other areas of life so I feel
like unless you're really blinded by
your emotions you're gonna be able to
see that oh you know what maybe my
partner is being a bit toxic or whatever
but because
um
you for whatever reason you want to stay
in that kind of situation or you might
find it hard to leave or whatever like
you take your time to leave or you just
don't yeah I actually really don't like
this word toxic I think yeah that's why
it's thrown about the players too much
uh it gets um it loses meaning I just
think it's just people understand it as
so many different things and so what is
toxic how do you summarize what's toxic
to you might not be toxic to somebody
else I just think it's a it's one of
those words social media everyone's
jumped on it now everything's toxic
toxic masculinity toxic femininity toxic
behaviors actually why don't we just
call it for what it is you're a shitty
person yeah you're you know whatever
you're arrogant or you haven't whatever
your ego artistically motivated or
whatever it is I just I think we use it
as like a filler word yeah to summarize
like loads of unnecessary yeah I think
there's got to be context behind any
particular behavioral trait that
someone's displaying you know I think
that a lot of people because they're
that they will use the word to almost
not explore the actual context behind it
and because sometimes people just don't
wanna that they don't want to spend
their energy explaining why somebody's
the way they are but I just want to like
find the word to describe to you like
this person is I think people are very
easily triggered you know even when you
know friends come to relationship eyes
now it's like oh these are red flags
this is toxic and it's like everything
is a red flag
especially you see with ik culture yeah
it culture makes me laugh I saw what
nellore said I get a ick when he walks
to the car and
it's like whatever
and then you've got like multiple Boys
on Snapchat
like and you're talking to them yeah I
don't especially if you say they're
convenient yeah I always think as well
if you don't want him doing it why are
you doing it exactly yeah if you don't
want her doing it why are you doing it I
agree yeah to some degree I think of a
red flag and a woman is a woman who has
a girl woman whatever who has loads of
male friends but she doesn't have any
female friends yeah yeah because that
shows me that she will be comfortable in
in that sort of okay great she's she's
great she connects with the guys
whatever but why are women not taking to
her I'm not saying that she must have
multiple you know a whole handful of
friends
yeah do you think it's a red flag if a
woman is slept with a lot of men yes a
little bit because it's like a little
bit a little bit because if it was you
don't know when they were younger
and maybe surrounded by the wrong say a
bunch of girls and was like their
mindset was like that so she just went
along with it like that and then grew up
and then was like I'm not actually like
that I didn't want to do that I didn't
want to do those things because I'm a
woman I don't like to do those things
like men do right then not so much
because she's realized it if I go but
would you rather your brother date a
girl that had that past or didn't have
that past that didn't do that see I I
actually haven't
I haven't thought about if it's a red
flag or not because the way that I see
it is
I don't really care how many partners
you've had before me and maybe some men
care I've met men that don't care
because what is done before is
irrelevant obviously yeah if you're
clotting everyone and you're walking
down the street and men are just
approaching you left right hey and you
know that she's really put it out there
then yeah that that's a huge issue but
that would be an issue for anybody if I
was walking down the street with a guy
and every five seconds a woman is
walking up to him do you think women
um feel that way about Drake women are
lined up to sleep with Drake and he
slept with loads of women do you think
women care but the standard for men and
women is so different you're right
especially in this DNA he's like a guy
he couldn't have slept with a hundred
women and he'll get spuds for it or
he'll get ratings or whatever let a girl
sleep with more than 10 guys she's a
hope for Life branded but I I do think
that it is slightly and it is a double
standard and and I don't know you know
I'm a woman I don't want to like jump
ship on like Womanhood and everything
and whatnot but it is different I feel
like it is different to you know
to allow a man into your
Sacred Space don't get me wrong you can
be you can be comfortable you can be you
know promiscuous as much as you want you
could love sex that's okay you can do
whatever you want but I think
think that it's poor sexual hygiene to
let so many guys so you would say it's a
red flag also it's I get I get yeah let
me not let me answer the question I
hadn't thought about it before we could
say yes but I would probably say now if
she's if she's overly promiscuous and
just puts it out there without any moral
any sexual morals whatsoever then yeah
that'll be but then yeah that'll be a
red flag I would say something you think
red flag yeah I think that if it's an
attitude which is a very casual attitude
towards sex and that is a red flag yeah
um you both said yes you what about you
yeah I hadn't thought about it but
hearing everybody's
um takes on it yes it is quite a sacred
thing and if you don't give it the value
that it has and you're just like
whatever with it then you don't respect
yourself what do you what do you guys
say to to women that say men are
insecure for feeling that way
it's not an insecurity I think it's
perfect for women as I think we know
also
it's not as good for us as it is for men
so why would we want well me personally
anyway what's not as good for us as it
is
the majority of women yes no not
necessarily the ACT but like you know
they always finish
energetically tied to the men that we
sleep with and I think that it's like
it's a you know it's an energy exchange
and again if you're sort of sleeping
with multiple men and you're taking on
that energy as well it spiritually I
feel it does affect you and and a lot of
women actually are depressed and all
kinds of things because of also because
I believe there is an aspect of actually
taking on the energy of all these
different people so you believe in Soul
tires in it yeah I do believe in that I
can't I believe in them to an extent as
well like basically for anyone who
doesn't know what it is it's when you
basically sleep with someone and their
energy kind of comes into you and yours
goes into theirs and it's like you start
I don't know not taking their traits
yeah you're almost like you almost take
on from the DNA yeah it's like almost
taking like their traits into account
it's like a spiritual thing like he said
yeah I feel like as well because I'm
religious as well I feel like it's a
thing like that maybe sleep with a
certain person say they've got I don't
know
you're gonna attract some of those I I
feel that way and there's a thing that
we do as humans it's like pair bonding
so actually there's a hormone that gets
released when you have sex with the same
person you know particularly multiple
times that we actually do release these
hormones which
um sends a signal to our brain that
we're actually going to be like
procreating with this um person so I
feel like that is damaging in the long
run if we're just doing that with people
that we don't have that intention with
yeah yeah 100 but at the same time as
well you see where it comes to all this
I don't know Soul tires the emotional
kind of bonded and stuff I feel like
personally men don't really get that I
feel like you can sleep with a guy say
you've been talking to this guy for ages
he could have one thing in his mind and
he can be saying okay well I'm just here
to do it and then go but at the same
time if you start actually catching
feelings for this guy when you sleep
with him it's gonna amplify but he might
not feel the same way and because I feel
like they don't get attached as easily
as we do so I feel like for somebody to
be sleeping with people that much
they don't really have like how do you
have feelings I feel like you feel even
just a physical act of what happens with
men and women is that you know the men
release don't they and then they're
relieved and they go as women we receive
it all so even the egg you know when it
gets implanted is like we've received
that we've and the baby then grows in us
they don't have that experience so
that's where genetically you know we are
made differently bird guy say that they
don't even know if they like you until
they've slept with you
do you think can I ask a question do you
think that women get post I don't want
to say oh it sounds so cringe but we're
just gonna drop it do you think women
get like post Finnish Clarity see the
way that guys get post not Clarity no do
you think women get that I can't lie
like as soon as you finish you think
actually I didn't really need to do that
I didn't really want to do that oh do
you think women get that kind of like as
soon as that as soon as the ACT is
finished it's like actually you can just
go home
a woman is very no masculine energy
probably I think so and you know what I
think so I said yes but then I just
thought like it depends who it is if
you're yeah it literally depends who it
is
I think
I don't know
yeah I was just curious without going as
you just said men sometimes men don't
even have to like the woman that they
have sleep that they have sex with this
is just a blood flow to their organ that
they have now used they're finished and
now I would say not like at first but I
could see some some girls that like
have had sex so much that they kind of
just start acting like dudes you know
what you said yeah I'm like I could see
that a little bit Yeah so um one thing
so I told you guys earlier that with
Tommy and Pamela that Tommy went to jail
for beating her right you guys I said
that earlier okay just making sure he
went to jail for like roughly six months
okay
and it it honestly it didn't paint
either of them in the best light but it
didn't clearly didn't paint him in the
best light a lot of people don't know
that she hit him first
do you think that women should be able
to press charges for assault if they hit
first I think that personally obviously
it might sound a bit mad but it depends
on the situation I'm gonna give you two
scenarios so cool you got one girl and I
don't know they're getting a heated
argument she slapped her man does that
give the man the right to come and not
stop pounding on her with all his
strength knowing that genetically men
are actually stronger than women like if
she's giving you one slap why does that
give you the right to come and beat her
up to the point where she's bleeding on
the floor so surely she should know if
he's physically stronger than her why
are you putting your hand on him okay
but why it's just us sorry sorry
and second scenario because I'm not
gonna lie even though it might made me
sound like a bad person I've seen it
I've seen certain girls who
intentionally provoke men so it's like a
thing where like she's gonna slap you
you're gonna stop her she's gonna keep
hitting you you gotta stop her because
you know you're stronger but it gets to
the point where he's only human he can
only take so much yeah so I feel like
I've seen that to the point where a girl
is actually provoking himself so much I
couldn't even get him to get her off and
all of this stuff so it's like I can't
like look I didn't even blame him but
she was doing too much that she made the
guy bleed from time I saw blood draw
from his cancer I think women take
advantage of the fact that they know
that men are not supposed to hit them
yeah but it's like how far can you go
before that you can't you expect to hit
back how about your stone I used to
genuinely think you should never hit a
woman until until I saw the type of hits
and punches that these women were
throwing and I I'd never grown up around
women that that acted like that but I'm
like if you're gonna hit like a dude
expect to get him like dude where did
you where did you see that just like on
Twitter and stuff you can see you could
see oh my gosh you've never seen the
videos come up on Twitter where the
girls are just like beating on the guys
and then he just snaps and like hits her
back and it's one punch and she's on the
floor and now yeah but but you
respectfully nobody deserves anyone to
to hit them because just keep your hands
to yourself if you're gonna hit somebody
expect I think if you're gonna hit
somebody you should expect to hear them
back and actually it's really
challenging as a mother of a son to like
what is the best thing to teach him
because ultimately I teach my son that
he shouldn't put his hands on girls
but if a woman is if a girl is hitting
him and attacking him what can he then
hit her back I took this social media I
took this to Instagram and the unanimous
response so from the guys it was yeah if
she hits him he should be able to hit
her back and every single female
answered no it doesn't matter how many
times she hits him a man shouldn't hit a
woman do you know that it must be hard
as a mother because you know that there
might be consequences for him if he does
hit back it's really true especially in
the U.S like there are men that have
called the police for a woman abusing
him and they arrested him yeah because
she'll just cry and play the victim and
say it was him yeah and so it's like you
you know I always say equal rights equal
laughs but it's like in all in all
serious what do you tell them to do what
are the the boys thing what do you think
if a girl hits you would you hit her
back wait raise your hand guys if you
think equal rights equal lefts are you
hitting the girl back
[Laughter]
what if she doesn't stop are you hitting
her I'm groove it for someone else but
me personally like someone else
because if you compare me to one of
these two
I feel like they could probably kill me
in like three punches yeah but you can
hurt them though I can hurt them but
have you ever heard them say like oh you
hit like a girl
you know what I mean you know yeah we
can hit but they can literally kill with
bare hands so then you should be aware
of that before you're throwing hands so
have you ever
um
for what I was gonna say never mind
he was raising his hand go ahead
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Game Changer I wouldn't hit her but she
picks up a wake up a weapon she's she's
going to sleep yeah but that's different
if she's just using her hands I've got
women are so much smaller than men as
well I know they can hear but they can't
really like off so many times have you
ever have you ever seen okay we have
Dwayne The Rock Johnson right
okay what if blessing goes up to Dwayne
The Rock Johnson
should he not and he he decks him right
should Dwayne The Rock Johnson not hit
him back because he's much bigger
exactly but he's no no it's nobody yes
okay but I feel like no no it's yeah
this is what happened wait saying
blessing right there that's blessing
yeah okay he goes up to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson you know do you know who that is
yeah okay big big dude yeah he hits him
in the face should we feel bad for
blessing if he gets knocked the hell out
because he hit him first
um no but he's also a man so why is it
different for men and for women because
clearly Dwayne The Rock Johnson is way
stronger than blessing because women are
so much weaker physically but there are
some weak men he's so much weaker than
have you seen the rock I've seen the
rock also you don't this guy could train
on the side he could be physically
strong just because he's tall enough
also listen like
I think it's just it's not really a fair
chance of someone like if a kid keeps
like banging at you or someone who's
smaller than you keeps banging it a kid
is Not Gonna Knock You Out okay
yeah but is a woman Gonna Knock a man
out okay look at like this with their
bare hands
I mean that only fans model in Florida
killed her I saw that yeah I killed him
she did she killed him and also there
are female Fighters that are like diesel
yeah there are female Fighters but like
maybe like a normal woman
but then but then where do we draw the
line like okay if you if you weigh a
certain amount if you have a certain
amount of like if you lift a certain
amount yeah
man is it not I think this is just a man
I'm not saying anyone is okay at all I'm
not I don't think anyone should hit
anyone let's be real yeah because no one
should I'm just saying I just feel like
more so men should restraint more to
that because they could do serious
damage but to what extent do they have
to restrain themselves
to what extent like what would you say
is the point where it's like okay cool
like at this point it's okay for me to
hit her back yeah I was saying well no
point but so what if this guy called let
me get a scenario
so this girl has come I don't know if I
can see all of this one here but this
guy is coming off I know yeah
let's say she's got a weapon yeah that
one could penetrate your skin she comes
and she stab you boom yeah and you're
there like she keeps doing it doing it
doing it to the point where you're not
bleeding so much but you know you can
still look at this girl to save your
life you're telling me the man shouldn't
do it no he should because she's
stabbing you
okay yeah so you should make your skin
so you think if it got to the point
where a woman is taking it too far then
the women the man should have a right
yeah when she's about to enter that's
what I want to kill you yeah but why why
does he have to wait till that point
exactly
I think
it's not to wait until that point as
well is to save his life yeah but the
I think she could maybe hurt him but
never as much as he could hurt their her
and I think everybody knows that that
happens do you know much domestic
violence happens where women where women
are domestically abusive towards men and
it's even worse because let's say they
go to report it no one's taking them
seriously and this is why men's mental
health and and you know that there are
so many other ones bring down the tone
of the chat and stuff but it is very
common very very common and it's not
taken seriously yeah but ultimately
doesn't want to be like women apparently
they don't want to talk about it no no
they do want to take a talk about it but
because of the stereotype of oh you're a
man you're tough right what do you mean
this woman just hit you come on man up
there is this stigma that men have to be
tough and men can't be so they do I
don't know I don't know if most men
really I mean you guys could correct me
if I'm wrong I don't think most men
would want to admit that their girl was
beating them up like I think that's kind
of embarrassing to a guy yeah I agree
I've got a friend who who was in a
relationship with a woman and and she
like she when she got angry and when she
was drinking she would hear she would
throw things at him she'd hit him she'd
she'd provoke it and every time that
happened he'd leave the house he'd leave
the house and then he'd come back and it
just got worse and worse and worse and
worse but he held that it happened where
by the time he told me it was going on
for like two years but he didn't tell
anyone because as you said there is an
what do you mean your woman's beating
you up what do you mean there is this
stigma around men being tough and not
being able to be runnable in those
situations and I don't think it's
acceptable the message is keep your
hands to yourself and if you're not
going to then you need to expect that
there's a possibility that they're going
to hit you back yeah that's awful but
yeah everyone just just keep their hands
to themselves no one should be hitting
anyone in a Kumbaya world I think I
think that would be lovely but this is
yeah we're not there and it's not but
it's just like
you know what people should do but I
know that's not the case obviously but
also I just always think maybe
I don't know if just someone Rico is
hitting you are they hurting you as much
did you know that most abuse is mutual
so in most abusive relationships the
parties are hitting each other and
actually in one-sided abuse what do you
think is more common meditating women
one-sided or women hitting men one-sided
look at blue face on Christian I know
you guys have seen them there we go blue
face is more scared ahead and she is a
him there we go she's pretty scary do
you think now blueface should not hear
her back I was thinking that girl's
crazy yeah no I those two I I actually
cannot but they're not wait she has no
teeth because of why because of him I
have no clue I'm not gonna lie to you
but at the same time this girl I heard
that's on some Snapchat video whatever
he's on the phone like he's making a
tick tock and she's like yo babe
like he actually acts scared of her like
they they asked her why he stayed and
he's I forgot what he said he was like
I'm already in this far like I already
did all this I'm like what are you doing
too deep it reminded me of the Amber and
Amber Rose is Amber Rose and Johnny Depp
Amber Heard sorry yeah yeah that was
that that listening to that court case
that was very much like that wasn't it
it was they were both no but that was
her more so her more yeah after watching
that it goes to show you that a lot of
women actually played the victim card a
lot and more time there the toxic ones
in the relationship because at the end
of the day if it wasn't for that court
trial this guy was getting canceled he
was getting taken off so much things
like he's so successful and she was just
trying to come and bring him down and
after all that she still wanted to go to
do a retrial didn't she didn't want to
accept that decision but look at her
backfired on her she got fired from her
stuff that's crazy with this too because
she Pamela Anderson literally they were
on and off for years okay she he went to
jail even though she hit him first
and on top of that she's doing a
documentary about it and she wrote a
book about it and now she has the
audacity to text him at 55 and say you
were my one true love wait did she say
that he replied no no no
um I mean he's definitely the one that
keep really limb back in I think yeah
yeah she said I can't believe it's kind
of like cut off because it's in the
documentary but it says
we were it's I think that says they were
young I can't believe they filmed so
much it's heartbreaking in a good way so
much love we were happy so cute with you
with the boys as babies and it's really
how the paparazzi World tore us apart
um it was very emotional and sweet I
have only good things to say about you
especially in hindsight I realized I
only had one true love I never recovered
um it's hard and I regret the pain I
caused
each other to dwell anything on the
negative it's the truth yeah but he's
like married now so he I don't think he
was so just leave the guy in peace
that I mean that's what you should do
but yeah are there any money if he come
knocking at a door she'd open up
wouldn't she oh yeah fully if she's
saying not just the door yeah but then
she's had him you know spend time in
jail she's you know been talking about
him the last 10 years she's made his
life a misery probably for a long time
yeah so what does that make him if he
goes back to her well he's not crazy oh
but these men you never know these men
well he didn't reply to us so it's
interesting how she uses the paparazzi
is the reason they didn't work out she's
not very accountable all that that's
happened it's down to the photographers
it's their fault that we broke up
on again off again abusive and she
married someone else too with I was um
Kid Rock and then after she they
divorced and she was like right back
with Tommy that's crazy so it's like she
had a guy that you know allegedly would
treat her well yeah and then you wonder
why guys when did they get married again
how
1995 I think it said but they got
married within like three days of me
three days three days lasted when was
the last time I think it was five years
ago from now so it was 1990
4 to
2018. yeah and I think sometimes we
forget well I'm not we forget but in
some cases with women and men I guess is
what you think is the norm so you know
somebody who identifies love as like
chaotic and wild windy and you know on
and off on off on off that thrill that
excitement that um up and down emotions
and stuff they will continuously go for
people that they fill that with because
that's what they know to be loved that
feeling of that whole butterflies and
it's all excitable and it's all chaotic
as I said that whole roller coaster of
emotions that is what they believe it to
be and so that that's what they chase it
sounds like Pamela Anderson certainly
she believes that he is the one for her
her one true love when we look at it on
paper it looks like a [__] show but
that's what she believes is love and I
think other people that don't I think
that's what kind of plays into what we
were talking about earlier about
toxicness because I feel like a lot of
relationships on paper will look one way
but when you're there experiencing it
for yourself like you're gonna feel a
whole different type of emotions than
the person who's actually just reading
your story if that makes sense like you
can somebody can read something and be
like oh like for example Christian and
Blue Rock we always judge these law but
we don't know what's going on behind
closed doors we don't know what emotions
they're going through we don't know what
he says to her what she says to him we
don't know that kind of bond that they
have it's more but we just see what we
see if that makes I think it's
attachment it's not Bonds attachment
style attachment one it's like the same
word an upbringing childhood childhood
trauma that has been unresolved you know
where they've had to grow up in a a
house where they've maybe experienced
abuse I mean even Chris Brown and the
Rihanna situation you know he was able
to link back to the fact that he did see
domestic abuse in his actually he also
was hitting him too yes exactly and
she's she's obviously got some childish
stuff probably that she was dealing with
I'm not saying we can always blame it on
our childhood but I do think that's why
a lot of people really do need to be in
therapy or something to process you know
so that it doesn't continue into your
adult relationships and become an
unhealthy pattern the other thing is as
well in terms of like people going
therapy and stuff I feel like this stuff
is so normal now that nobody really
feels like they actually need help
because it's like everybody kind of goes
through obviously it's not good but
there's so many broken marriages they
bring up children they kind of see the
same kind of Cycles growing up and then
when it comes to relationships they
reflecting the same kind of things like
you said about before like girls not
having their dads you see people your
mom your dad's hitting your mom like
they just bear different stuff that
people that people go through and it's
like people like used to have families
that used to support them through their
relationships and they could actually
get advice from but now it's like a lot
of people are born in like you said
single parent homes and they don't have
sib like they've maybe one sibling who
do they go to yeah
and look at what we see on the internet
or a stranger therapist like when you
think about it I was thinking about this
I don't want to say I don't believe in
therapy okay I don't want to say I don't
because I do think like in short term
they can teach you tools to help
yourself but I was thinking I'm like you
you could either go to your stranger
that you don't know about a problem or
you could go to your family
what makes more sense but sometimes
people don't have that support system
yeah sometimes the therapy is for the
family yeah what sometimes the therapy
is for the family maybe yeah I think in
it's also a cultural thing maybe because
I mean sorry did you say you're from a
Muslim cultural background as well did
you say that earlier yes yeah because
I've I know that in the marriage
breakdown within that you don't just go
straight to divorce you have to kind of
go to other people in the community and
all of that before you make that
decision isn't it can you give
can you give me a bit of background on
that what the process is with regards to
breakups and divorces and within the
community I was gonna say this as well
um um previously anyway so when you um
are in a relationship I feel like going
to a therapist or family all these kind
of things should always be like
um the second to last resort because at
the end of the day everyone's going to
give you their opinion based on their
perspective and like you said no one's
actually in the relationship so things
can be um very negative and all these
kind of things but there may be little
things about yourself or about your
partner you may not be given an
objective story there's so many
different factors but to just directly
that's what I think too like because if
you go to a therapist they're not going
to know the backstory your family does
yeah your family's only going to know
about show them as well yeah but like
they know you so like if my sisters had
has a problem with her boyfriend like
I've known my sister since she was a kid
so if she tells me a story I'm gonna
have a little bit more context than a
stranger yeah I'm not saying I don't
believe like I think therapy's needed
because of the breakdown of the family
structure but I feel like we have so
much therapy nowadays because we don't
have families anymore yeah we don't have
a stable family like if you had a stable
group of people I got I don't know you
guys backgrounds but if you have a able
group of people that love you and want
what's best for you aren't they better
than a stranger who doesn't know you do
you know what it is for me I feel like
it's all like I literally understand
everything you're saying and it works
out well that way sometimes but at the
same time like you said you don't know
everybody's family situation some people
could be coming from a very biased kind
of family so people could be biased and
I don't know you might say for example
you've got a dispute with your mum not
necessarily the relationship but like
family wise you've got to speak to your
mom you might have like I don't know
your cousins your aunties everybody
taking your mom's side and nobody really
taken into account what you're saying so
I feel like the therapist comes in where
it's kind of biased I'm non-biased sorry
so the therapist will come in non-biased
so basically from what I gather they
will try to take your I don't know
they'll try to ask cool like Jackie
like tell me about yourself to ask you
some questions then ask blah blah blah
and then they're trying to piece things
together they'll ask you who your
version of events their version of
events I agree with like short term
right I think I think therapists can be
helpful for like short term but I'm just
thinking like because even even like
before the average used to be five kids
so you all four siblings aren't going to
take your mom's side there's one that
likes the dad you know what I mean yeah
like and so I just feel like a lot of
times we have this surplus of like
everyone's got a therapist in in society
because we don't have the families that
we're supposed to have there's a
breakdown of the family unit yeah yeah
can I just um finish answering the
question you asked me
curious about that yeah sorry about that
sorry everyone
um but yeah I was just gonna say after
you um deal with things internally and
you cannot deal with it internally then
you have to go to
um your parents and your grandma and
stuff and if even then you cannot and
things like divorce and going to um you
go to the Imam so then you go to like
the religious leader and all these kind
of things and if after all of these
different Avenues you've tried your
hardest then obviously there's other
options that are not so great yeah but
it's like a yeah
that's it we're getting divorced you
need to talk to everybody about it first
don't you I think that's a good thing
it's not necessarily therapy as well
because it's like religious on your
family coming from those perspectives
I'll tell you something else that kind
of red pilled me about therapy okay so I
moved to London to play volleyball and I
got basically a free degree when I came
here and I really wanted something easy
so I picked psychology okay because when
I was an undergrad all the psychology
students just had the easiest time and I
was like I want that because I didn't
really want a master's degree I didn't
really care you know I just came here to
play volleyball and have fun and I just
could not believe all the girls in those
classes were crazy yeah I'm like who
this is the therapist that are coming up
these are the people giving advice I was
like oh no I find that in the coaching
industry as well a lot of people have
not got their life together and they're
giving they're selling big coaching
packages but that's why it's like with
the family you at least know who you're
talking to you you at least know that
they're crazy yeah so if you're getting
advice from someone you you know what
they are and it's free yeah
it's like a therapist is is just a
stranger I'm not anti-therapy like
there's PTSD but I just see how bad
therapy is nowadays I'm like this can't
be better than your family I agree with
me with what you're saying I feel like I
agree with you what you're saying
because it's good for short term I don't
know you might have like one big family
Disco agreement and you go therapy so
without them but I don't think that it
should be for you to lie for life to go
to a therapist and speak your whole
heart out and your whole life because at
the end of the day they don't really
care they're just there to get paid and
move on with their life so I feel you in
that sense but also what I said about
the whole non-biasing I feel that comes
into account for short-term scenarios
like if you've got a one argument you're
trying to solve with like I don't know I
used to watch My Wife and Kids I don't
know if you could watch that I remember
when Jay and Michael who went to um like
therapy and that they used to go for
them that small stupid arguments and
that they'll go get it solved in that I
know it's TV but it makes sense and you
go there for little disputes you don't
go there to spill out your whole life
and and get resolutions I don't think
that makes sense yeah my personal
experience with therapy was awful so I
agree with you I really yeah I had a
really good experience actually because
yeah well this is the thing because I
went and I remember
I okay the thing is with therapy right
so you get it all out get out what
you're meant to talk about and then say
one week you feel really good I don't
want to talk about it I don't want to
talk about this thing that I have to
repeat every week and then so I said
like oh um can we skip this week and
maybe I'll come next week and the answer
was no like I need my money this week oh
that's outrageous I would have fired the
therapist right away well she said it
was it's a process oh and then she like
corrected it oh I mean you need to come
this week it's all uh
I feel like it forces you to and she
brings things up sometimes or she he
they like make you talk about things
sometimes and pinpoint things that
sometimes aren't exactly that true and
because she's your therapist you then
start to believe things that actually
didn't even exist anyway yeah so now I
remember one
let's try to make my mum and my sister
be like the bad people in my life that
this is nothing about them and then my
mind started stirring and I came out and
she went I just wasn't talking to them
and I was like then overthinking it for
myself and then I was like this has
nothing to do with them I don't even
know how it went that way it's like they
it's like it altered my like mind you
know what else I was thinking about I
was thinking what is their incentive to
get you but your family okay has an
incentive to get you better they can't
have you crazy because they have to deal
with you all right but the therapist
they're paid if you get worse
so what incentive I'm not saying there
aren't good therapists there certainly
aren't it's certainly needed but in
general I'm like I feel like a family
unit would be better for most problems
rather than a stranger it would uh yeah
and and they tell you what you want to
hear because if you're paying them like
there's so many times where I'll have a
friend like tell me what she said to her
therapist and I'm just thinking she's
lying to you like I know you and that's
what I was thinking when she was saying
about my mom and my sister
they're like we're great by the way and
it's like that's something else that
she's made maybe for me to go back then
be like what did you mean about that
maybe we should talk about it and more
and then her bank account is going up
and up and up and mine's going down and
up and down yeah and then I've got more
more problems I think there are
definitely different different levels to
therapy
um some more in depth than others um I
had a therapist for a short time but it
was more for like CBT which is cognant
behavioral therapy so I wanted to
understand
um why I sort of process the things that
the way that I do like I'm a massive
overthinker and so it was more so to
kind of hone in and understand that
about myself a bit more and then have
mechanisms that can help me manage that
um and I found her to be fantastic but
then it was just about me if that makes
sense it wasn't so much about like
relationships with other people and
things like this of course you touch on
it yeah
um but it was a very personal thing and
I found it really enlightening
um and I guess yeah I could have gone to
my family for sure to understand that
but I think a lot of people don't want
to be accountable for where they may
contribute to something that you don't
understand about yourself or something
that you may feel you do that you're
trying to manage or get a hold on
um and so yeah I definitely think it's
it's a it's a broad sort of spectrum as
far as therapists what their intentions
are how they can help you what you go
there for and staff but I think that we
always know the answers deep down think
sometimes we just want somebody else to
sort of validate us and for me it wasn't
um it wasn't a financial thing it was
more of a this person has studied this
and has the tools and has learned has
their degree or whatever it is in this
specific field and can help me
possibly I swear to God they're not
possibly I had some CBT therapy not many
sessions it was like free on the NHS as
well which was good and that was more
like a PTSD thing but I found that what
was really helpful for me was actually
reading and finding the right kind of
books to read and you can learn yourself
actually yeah not not saying there's no
good there's definitely needed there's
definitely ones that are necessary but I
think the most are crazy
I'm gonna say this being in the program
I respect it um I think I'm actually
going to wrap up the show so uh why
don't we go around everyone give any
final thoughts you have have any peace
you want to say you know within you know
like 30 to 45
starting there and go around
um I'll go lost okay all right I mean I
don't know what I'm gonna say let's just
freestyle it okay cool so ultimately
what I've taken away from this is that
um everyone kind of has their own demons
and I definitely think that you should
sort of you know be a bit more in touch
with yourself and understand who you are
what you want what you don't want
instead of you know burdening that on
other people I think that we should be
kind to each other I think you don't
really know what people are dealing with
until you really hone in on it
um and I also think that you should keep
your hands to yourself and I've had a
great time here um on the on the show
thank you so much to everyone
um yeah that's it
yeah it's been great just to hear
everyone's perspectives I'm still
reflective mode and I'm hungry so I'll
probably say
but yeah it's been
um I've also had a great time on the
podcast and following me on Instagram at
Amber underscore underscore for tennis
um yeah I just want to say thank you for
having me on here it's been really
insightful to hear everybody's opinions
and see how everybody thinks that she
said please keep your hands to yourself
um but yeah um I hope everybody took
something away from here today
I still haven't really thought about
what I want to say so um before I came
on this I said to my friends that what I
really think about the world is that
everyone's a little bit [__] but you
have to bring out the good parts of you
and try and share that with other people
so I guess that's just it really
oh and sis if he's making you go through
it that is not your man
okay I'm gonna read the last Super chats
that people sent also guys make sure you
like the video the like is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams so make sure you
like the video on your way out um leave
a comment let me know what topics you
guys want me to cover next week
um Francisco R I actually grew up with
an abusive mother and I never realized
how toxic she was for about 15 years
I've seen her hit my dad and
unfortunately because I didn't know
better I sided with her avenox
um women always shame men for not
wanting a woman with past or baggage
however they are quick to use trauma and
bad family as a crutch to dodge present
accountability make that make sense
dragon's stallion um do you think
marriage is about Duty or responsibility
or solely to your happiness
um that'd be a good show topic actually
I'm gonna write that down
um H Garvis
um
Pamela met her match she couldn't handle
the attention he was getting Tomo wait
till you find out men love deeper and
more true than you are capable of those
men 404s now though um Alex I don't
understand women that think they won't
there won't be a response from the guy
even a moderately a moderate man
physically is far stronger stronger
if they try pull up the video of the
eight-year-old fighting a woman and pins
her an eight-year-old wow okay
Maurice self-defense is a god-given
right um Ray Zach if she hits film it
Tomo J red flag for women I'm 30 years
old 30 years old without a ring um Tomo
J questioned for the 30 plus year old
women every time I went to go for a
long-term relationship with an
age-appropriate woman I hear what you
sounded like 10 years ago and I can't
get over it sounds so Insidious not
innocence tips H all biological level I
believe men need to feel needed in the
relationship and that's why men usually
find fat women unattractive as she
doesn't need men to provide food
why um women and Why women's body count
matters
um 93 top high Pearl is a great example
of hypergamy she wants a high value chat
with low value reading I'm sorry sorry
Pearl but you're no good at reading look
it I know uh bodybuilding lifestyle my
oh I read that one already okay
um a couple announcements guys before we
close out the show I'm the first
um so our shows last week um I know I
Gaslight you guys a little bit I said we
were live we didn't do them live because
we had Nick Fuentes on and he's such a
controversial character
um we have the full episodes or I think
one the second is going to be released
on Rumble we just have Clips on the
channel those episodes were actually
really really funny
um I really wish we could have uploaded
the full things because I think you
would have really enjoyed it so go to
our Rumble the link to that is in the
description
um
also our new show schedule is going to
be Thursdays and Saturdays our aim is to
start at 8 30. um we haven't got there
yet but we're really trying
um blessing's gonna get us there right
blessing
yeah yeah
um also we're thinking about doing a
Meetup in London um I think we're just
gonna go to like a coffee shop or
something I'm gonna tell people to come
so follow my Twitter pearly things if
you want to be updated on when and where
that's going to be
um also guys make sure you subscribe to
the channel and subscribe to our two
clips channels just for eclipse and
pearl daily sign up for our four
membership tiers the first gets you to
be a part of the chat the second you get
to be a part of our Discord and our
behind the scenes blogs third connect
with me on social media fourth is a
one-on-one call where I can tell you how
to get a million subscribers in a year
um Instagram go follow my Instagram
justpirely things one
um also subscribe to wife school um if
you want to see you know modern women
turn into wives go subscribe to wife
school
um animation Channel just pearly
animations and also we're looking I
think in the next two weeks or so we're
probably gonna add a day of the week
where we're gonna go live so I was
thinking Tuesday or Wednesday let me
know which day you think would be better
in the chat what day do you guys want
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time